meeting shall notice for this this
meeting notice complied with house rul
and RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
271-3600 or email
HCS
l.st doh. Us in the event the public is
unable to access the meetings meeting
will be adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that is on the meeting assisting
us Brad Greenland committee
research please note that all votes are
taken during this meeting shall be by
roll call vote let's start the meeting
by taking a roll call in
attendance each member states their
presence please also State whether there
is anyone in the room with you during
this meeting this is required under the
right to no
La that ask the clerk to please call the
RO um representative gunky here gunky
gouls representative gold is here and
I'm
alone
representative harb I am present and I
am in my office and presently
alone representative harb is present
representative pron I'm present and I'm
in the committee room representative
pron is present representative Dodge
good morning I'm president
andalon represent Dodge is
present uh representative Harvey b as
present representative Healey here
representative he is here in the
mville representative Mayville is here
and
alone representative present
representative
post I am present and I am in a loft
room and I have speakers on and there
will be people going below me but I do
speaker and headon
ones
post representative Smith I am here at
and I am at my home office
[Music]
alone representative Smith is present
representative
she's on the I am here I am here and I
am
alone representative Spang president
representative
grassie representative grassy I'm here
and
alone representative uh grass is here
representative goling home and
alone representative goling is present
from
okay um representative
Connors representative Connors is here
I'm in my office and I'm alone
representative Connor is present
representative
Vale I'm here um I am alone in my
office representative Bale is present
representative
Kelly representative Kelly is here and
I'm
alone representative Kelly is present
and representative
Moran representative Moran is present
and
sorry
we will we will start the Committee
hearing uh within hopefully a few few
minutes we looking
three
sh
I'm I'm I'm G to start do
have list of people who
have S in testimony we get started on
the get started and hopefully we will
have
the the uh list of attend of uh people
who wish to be mo V filled out their
attendees and representative renilla if
if I may I have the list up in front of
me if um if you would want me to read
that off to you um
[Music]
I it should be on its way down now too
okay well I'm going to I'm GNA open the
meeting I'm G to
recognize representative Smith who is
the who is the Prime
sponsor
maybe get that information down us soon
as
possible
you ready for
just yes representative RZ I didn't hear
your question yeah uh the how many
people do you have on the list uh for
this bill I have um five who um put
their position and two
testifying two
testifying
who are the two to testify I
Thomas
spelly spell the last name
ohat she's on is an attendee okay all
right why don't we go go to it we I'll
start the
hearing okay open open the hearing and
311 J recognizes representative
Smith thank you Mr chair and good
morning members of the resources
Recreation and development committee I
am here today as Prime sponsor of House
Bill 311 establishing a committee to
study rail trail best management
practices I did send in written
testimony which I am not going to read
but I will briefly go over the bill and
what we have found um in last last year
when we had a similar a bill that kind
of talked about the rail Trails was that
many uh railroad beds that were
abandoned years ago um have remnants of
problems that were a result of Just The
Way railroads were built and there is
residual contamination there could be
oil contamination from oil and other
hazardous materials uh croso was used on
railroad ties and so best management
practices um for redeveloping these into
recreational
in um dealing with these problems
identifying and dealing with problems so
that the trails are safe for people who
walk ride their bikes use ohvs run push
baby stroll
Etc and the committee as it is designed
to be set up is a legislative committee
with four members uh it's a lot easier
to find four members than it is to find
20 members and these legislators could
easily ask for uh assistance and advice
and expert testimony from people who are
more knowledgeable than we legislators
on these issues so the one of the main
uh groups of people that they would
get uh information from are the state
agencies Department of transportations
with Transportation which handles uh
railroad corridors Department of Natural
and cultural resources Bureau of trails
which deal with recreational trails in
the state and um also yeah and that
would be and the Department of
Environmental Services as to the hazards
that could be present on these abandon
and rail beds there's also a list in the
Bill of things of other experts what
expert information uh the committee
would be looking for people who are
familiar with establishing bmps or best
management practices uh identifying
areas of contamination concern residual
contamination from railroad operations
and then the impact of motorized
vehicles on rail Trails pedestrian
impact on trails and the impact on a
butter along these recreational Trails
uh the the uh committee would be in
effect from now until the end of this
session which would be November of
2022 and hopefully uh would come up with
a uh list a best management practices
for the development or the maintenance
of rail Trails recreational rail trails
in the state and so I ask for you to
listen to the testimony and vote Yes to
support the bill I will say that uh
representatives from uh Department of
Natural and cultural resources division
of parks is here and also uh from the
Department of uh Transportation so if
the committee later has questions for
those folks um they are willing to
answer questions they have told me thank
you and I will take questions if you
would like to
ask there any
questions represent and Mr chairman a
question for representative
Smith um this is commendable I use the
trails all the time and and I'm from a
railroad family so I understand uh
having grown up on the main line of the
prr who my family did uh the question
I've got though is with all these great
state organizations already working on
it and having responsibility for that is
there not already such a set of
guidelines and and why do you need an
IAL committee if you've already got
State agencies that are responsible um
for these
activities well um thank you for your
question the last year we had a bill
requiring that the
state
remediate toxins contaminants hazardous
things that are on rail trails and
proposed rail trails and that was a very
cost would be a very cost costly
Endeavor and one of the suggestions made
to me by the former director of Bureau
of trails was putting together best
management practices which would be
educational and also help to determine
what would be the best steps to take and
so that is uh why this bill was
introduced there is there are no best
management practices in place in New
Hampshire for the development of rail
Trails although Massachusetts does have
them and one of the first things they
stay on their lengthy uh pamphlet on it
is that we have to assume there are
beds okay thank you
sure any other
one do you foresee uh that any
additional legislation coming uh out of
this uh
uh this from this committee or from from
the from this committee that uh this
Phill
requests I'm not sure how best
management practices if they are put
into statute I don't believe they are
because best management practices are
not law they don't us as far as I know I
mean someone might know a better better
than I but I know that when I look at uh
Timber
harvesting um there are best management
practices uh which go into a lot more
depth than um the statute does and they
are not administrative rules to the best
of my knowledge so therefore they do not
have the authority of
law thank you and I would welcome
correction if I'm wrong thank you uh any
uh any other
questions um representative Smith does
this would this committee work with um
law enforcement at all uh to mitigate
activities like crime in urban areas
along Urban sections
of that would be up to the I mean the
whatever is deemed important the
committee could call on people to help
them put together the best management
practices but since the bmps would be
for the development and the maintenance
of
Trails um I don't know if that would fit
in but that would be up to the committee
and uh the input They will receive from
the people that they are reaching out
to thank you any any other any other
questions any other members of the
committee uh behind the
screen seeing thatone thank you very
you former representative Wendy
Thomas
all right everyone can hear me okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna give guidance before you
start sure name
Town who you
represent how how long you plan to
speak and turn your video on we can all
see if you if you'd like we would the
committee would like it but again it's
not it's not a
requirement okay I don't I don't seem to
have a a link to turn my video on um
just to I just have the mute link so so
I'll just get started so um uh good
morning Mr chair and members of the
resources committee um I'm Wendy Thomas
former representative for the town of
marac I live in marac um and I'm here to
support House Bill
311 this is a case of we didn't know
what we didn't know last term my ohrv
work led me to write this bill in trying
to help the people who abut the rail
trails that are used for o ohrv traffic
I came across a document from
Massachusetts and realized that we have
no such standardized procedure manual
for New
Hampshire in working with the do and
train experts we heard of Health
threatening fugitive dust which is dust
that literally escapes from where it it
from where it's
from but in talking to e to the experts
we also heard that there are other
health concerns regarding these
abandoned train tracks the brakes used
asbestos the trains had spills fuel
leaked there is also a concern of pasas
in the soil we heard about some areas of
the rail trail where no vegetation grows
that's a concern the rail trails are
some of the jewels in New Hampshire's
crown we need to both protect them and
to protect the people who use them this
bill sets up a committee to establish
best practices for rail trail Management
in New Hampshire and it is based on what
Massachusetts has already done it would
look at ways to protect the land whether
that be testing and removal of
contaminated soil or planting vegetation
to curtail fugitive dust this bill would
help establish a state standardized
approach of Protec our rail trails and
the people who use them in New Hampshire
I urge you all to vote ought to pass on
you no questions
sir no questions at the table no any
questions behind the
screen there being none thank you very
much thank you I'm at a disadvantage of
because I do not have the list of uh
people who
uh who are behind who uh have who are
who's who is making comments on this
film um
the let me see if let me let me uh see
if's
now
is there
anyone is there anyone
else on the attendees who wish to be
heard please raise your hand I can turn
case Mr chairman no hands are
raised
being being thatone else I will I will
close
up all everything I think maybe I have
some
[Music]
information
just read I'll just read this
immediately and then pass it on
uh this will be the reading to the
record those who
are there one two five people
uh representative Smith and
representative Thomas have spoken uh and
then there's Ellen
sammon is part of a Gran State Wheelman
bicycle they
are they are in support of the
bill with that I will close the
hearing and I would like to open up an
executive session on this here on this
so
discussion I uh personally uh I I'll get
I'll start to where I where I
am the there are a lot of rail
trails in the in the
state
and they're they're basically railro
railroad
beds and what happens is a lot of them
are
transfer and they just uh and that's
just it they just transferred as far as
I my understanding well we really don't
know what we're giving
them and it ought to be
encumbered on state so before they give
stuff to folks
Ts that they are that there should be at
least we should at least look at what
we're giving and that is what this
committee that this bill proposes
establishes would establish a committee
to look at the best practices that
should be
done uh
when when we allow when we pass these
things over to the or put these into the
into the into public use and there are
best practices we we just don't know
what they are and this this committee
will look into it if you look at the at
the bill it
says the committee shall submit an
interim report of its findings and any
recommendations for proposed legislation
to the speaker and the House of
Representatives president and Senate Etc
in other words uh it's just it's just
doing due
diligence and it's it is something
we representative gunky thank you Mr
chair uh having had many conversations
with the honorable Wendy Thomas on this
particular subject matter I I do believe
such as yourself that this is this is
without question something that uh
should be strongly considered it's long
over do there's a lot of rail Trails not
a lot ofsight as to what's actually in
one anyone else any comments by or
questions
or so you have uh representative B
representative
D you're
recognized
representative gold yeah thank you for
letting me comment uh maybe as you know
uh I am aware that very many people in
the bicycling committee I mean Community
are interested in this bill and uh they
seem to be in favor of it and the rail
you anyone else wish to speak on this
bill representative Dodson uh
representative do you are recognized
good morning and thank you for taking my
question um is there a chance that this
committee May dissolve once its use is
done and over with once the best
practices are established or is this an
end I can answer that um representative
it it is uh it will end automatically in
November of
okay times uh when committees are passed
into law you know to develop a committee
it takes months before they actually get
started so what we vote on now uh may
not get to the house floor and then the
Senate and then have the governor sign
it until May or June which means August
September October would be three months
not really long enough which is why I
extended it to to the end of the session
session thank you representative do uh
by uh what happens is all
committees that are made up just of
Representatives at the end of the
session they they disappear they don't
you they would have to be
reintroduced at at the next session
good thank
you this committee will will disappear
does uh anyone else any other any other
questions or comments before we go into
voting L Mr chairman you have no other
questions representative goling had her
hand
up show up she didn't raise she's on the
screen
representative uh yeah uh in Reading the
bill representative Smith it talks about
Redevelopment uh would this also apply
to Trails that are already developed
that we would that would take a look at
that as
well
you any other questions any other
comments before we go into a voting
mode there's no one else with their
hands up Sir anyone else with their
hands
up House Bill
311 establishing a committee to study
representative the representative is
there a
heing would you like to speak uh to your
motion um I think it's all been said and
I support the
bill you'd like to speak to your second
representative it's pretty
straightforward it's something that's
needed I
think good is there any discussion on
Representatives disc No Hands ra all
right they being they being none on the
[Music]
motion to
pass clerk please call R yes
representative gunky representative
gunky votes yes representative gunky
wrot votes yes representative
G representative G yes
yes representative G yes representative
Horgan yes representative organ yes
representative harb
yes representative harb says yes
representative Kon representative Kon
says yes representative Kon says yes
representative Dodge yes representative
Dodge says yes representative Harvey
bolia says yes representative Healey
yes
says yes representative mville
representative mville says yes
representative Mayville says yes
representative
post I'm sorry yes representative post
says yes representative to says yes
representative
Smith yes representative Smith says yes
Spang representative Spang says
yes representative spank says yes
representative grassy representative
grassy says yes reprentative goling yes
representative goling says yes
representative
Cohen
yes representative Cohen says yes
representative Connors representative
Connor says yes representative Connor
says yes representative
Vale yes representative Vale says yes
representative
Kelly representative Kelly says yes
representative Kelly says yes
representative Moran representative
Maran says
20es
yes
that's
right all right the vote being
carries consent consent calar
any to have this go on consent any
okay we'll go on down thank you Mr Vice
chair uh any more business on this bill
there is one oh yes yes there is writing
of b or writing of the committee report
customarily you the maker of a motion
that I'll ask representative Smith if
she can
she might have something already written
representative Smith I do not have
anything written but my testimony should
provide good material for a uh for a
committee report and I can give a hand
if you need anything representative
Smith close the
executive
session and we
have 25 minutes till the next next year
mute
okay so you have that over there
that's I saw it on the street I said I
gotta move the mouse it's bothering me
this mouse is on the screen oh okay I'm
for you sir you're off mute repres
raised and she's onute unmute yourself
okay there we go
yes here I am late for the party what
can I what would you like well you have
your hand raise you have what do you
like oh yes um I'd like a cookie no I I
um I would like to to say something uh
relative to the next bill I was the
chair of the large groundwater uh
commission um and I would like I
disagree with the dees testimony when
would be the best opportunity for me to
say
something all right it's
just yeah representative yes you you
can't be speaking on on the
bill uh we we not until we go into op
session okay I guess the other option
would be for me to ask some pointed
questions of Dees when they testify we
oh most most
assuredly although not the most pop way
it whichever you prefer Mr chair you
could sign up to testify if you
wish Oh I thought it was to that had to
be done before this moment no you're
you're uh you
can I'll will allow representatives to
wish the
testify okay okay thank you I could
speak right after dees are you on the
bill excuse me you you are on the on 235
not
that's that's a good gu you cannot uh
you representative yes uh if you speak
on the bill that means you're testifying
that means you you know you you can you
cannot question the people okay okay
that's fine so you could either speak on
it or you could uh stay on the on the
committee specifically and during the
hearing and question other question the
tell the testimony but you can't get
testimony and
also question right that sounds familiar
great okay well I would choose to
testify then all right we'll put you on
the
uh put you on test
the the uh we'll put you on the list to
testify right after the
uh right after any other
Representatives okay thank you for your
courtesy Mr SP Mr
chairman thank you just a second
representative Smith has her hand raised
representative Smith has okay
representative Smith yeah um Mr chair I
just wondered if we were considering
executing uh the Two Bills or the uh at
least the uh house bill 193 the timber
trespass bill today during one of our
breaks uh we can uh we check what what
is the
uh I did check to find out you have you
have probably have the red
copies I emailed all the committee
members the amendment okay uh I did
check with the chief of staff and uh we
don't need to have the red copies in
hand
if everybody has a copy of the of the
Amendments you did send them out
yes so they should be in
your I do have one set of copies I can
pass
around look at
the New Hampshire for and anybody to
look well I would like to be able to do
that
let me see if I can work on
that okay yeah it depends how the next
Y and Mr chairman you have Mark Pearson
and representative
silver with their hand raised as
attendees okay we're not we're
will they're in the audience they're
just listening to our
yeah but you and representative G now
has your hand raised too we have three
representative okay represent okay of
the uh yes the microphone came on thank
you um about the bill that
representative Smith just mentioned is
that the one with the uh amendment that
we had last
year yeah are two bills that she
representative Smith has amendments on
at some point in
the the day we have some additional time
we'll have see if we can uh get those
taken
care H yeah but she mentioned the
amendment and I was wondering if if that
amendment is the one we had last
year one is on HB am I thinking
and other one is which is seasonal
platforms and the other one
is HB
193 was the which was yes that was the
timber one yeah uh she she said uh
representative
Smith uh sent out copies of the
committee we will that we will discuss
and we I have to look at that makes
certain that all of the members of the
committee have that Amendment those are
amendments and that's for House Bill
193 yes look look look in your look
representative Smith sent
out copies of her
amendments to the bill should uh
you you have uh Mark Pearson and Norm
silver with their hands raised Mr Mr
Pearson Senator Pearson you have a
question oh we are we are this is this
is not not the
hearing hearing is not started yet no I
was raising my hand to practice my hand
raising skills this is all very new to
me I'm ready to speak when you uh invite
me to Sir okay thank you representative
silver yes sir representative silver you
have uh you have a question know the
chair uh yes I do I on hb15 which is
scheduled for this afternoon I would
like to withdraw my opposition and
indicate that I no longer wish to speak
in
opposition
okay will
you
leard
ofes
but we also have so there's three
speakers listed y normally thees would
vot before the
member no but but if he's supporting
mute
call the committee
order this we're going have a hearing on
House Bill 235 relative to community
small water small groundwater
withdrawals chair
recognizes
pearon thank you Mr chairman and
unusually my um
uh is having a problem okay just a
second uh will you state your name town
you
represent uh the town uh who you
represent and the time you plan to speak
speak slowly and turn your video on if
me yes is he yes hear we can
hear I am
unmuted can can you hear
me breaking out
bit we may be able to
help Mr chairman point of
order yes we we may be able to help
stabilize his internet connection if we
temporary if people who are remote
temporarily disable our our video um so
uploaded that that sounds thats good uh
do uh if the people other on everyone's
off sir everybody is off thank you very
much I try it again
representative pear this is
representative Mark Pearson from
Hamstead I represent the ferial d uh
district and I'm chairman of health
human resources and elderly Affairs
Committee of the
house and I wish to introduce house
buillt 235 relative to community small
groundwater
withdrawal I'll try to be brief this
bill is in response to a problem that
arose in Hamstead a year and a half ago
a family discovered their well went dry
neighbors discovered that their Wells
were either going dry or the water
coloration had turned bad they hired Mr
Leonard sarus he's known as Lee sist who
is a hydro
geologist he procured maps of the
streams flowing underground a lot of
research was
done they came to the conclusion that
possibly the problem stemmed from the
Hamstead area water company drilling
Wells nearby and pumping large
quantities of water per day
the group of people in Hamstead did two
things first they filed a
lawsuit and Monday's Union Leader
newspaper uh related how an injunction
against Haw for overpumping is in force
pending the outcome of the trial the
second thing they did was to ask area
legislators to intervene not in a
retrospective way about their problem
but in a prospective way that similar
problems stemming from overpumping might
be
prevented Southeastern and South Central
New Hampshire are growing more water is
needed that's okay but it cannot be at
the expense of the wells that were
already drilled and are in use I
convened a meeting with all of the
legislators representing Hamstead I
invited three people from the Department
of Environmental Services to come I
invited Lee arpus the hydro
geologist and I also invited
representatives of Hamstead area water
company uh we are not interested in
putting anybody out of business and I
might say somewhat humorously all the
people who represent Hamstead are
Republicans we are not anti-business
but neither are we
anti- families losing their water
because of overpumping
we met several times we crafted the
language of Two Bills one passed
unanimously out of this committee last
year when on consent went to the Senate
got attached to an Omnibus Bill and is
in law a second Bill also came to this
committee passed unanimously went on
consent and went to the Senate and died
along with a number of other bills
because of
covid in the testimony that I gave but
more importantly Lee sarus he's the
scientist I mentioned that this bill was
the product of Department of
Environmental Services as well as the
legislators as well as our local
hydrogeologist there was however a
testimony given by someone from Dees
that was less than enthusiastic let's
put it that way I asked then chair
Suzanne Smith if I could have a chance
to speak to that and graciously she said
yes and let me read just a small portion
of what Rob Scott the commissioner of
Dees said in his letter currently New
Hampshire Dees does not have the
authority to require that a small
community water supply well applicant or
owner mitigate potential adverse impacts
to private water supply in the event
that impacts occur although there are
neither widespread reports nor a long
record of small community well impacts
to private Wells the increasing density
of development within the the state and
the use of small community water supply
systems at subdivisions to increase Land
Development
increases the likelihood for these
impacts in the
future um so it goes on to say that he
uh believes that the bills that uh we
brought would provide the dees authority
to require a mitigation plan be
developed and so on and that is signed
Robert Scott commissioner so whatever an
individual from Dees may
say the
commissioner thanked us for giving him
the authority to deal with a problem
which he
recognized now the bill before you today
is a variant of that second bill that
died in the Senate it's tweaking here
and there and frankly if anything and I
do not mean a pun here we watered it
down a little bit from last time well I
think you can tell uh I am not a
scientist but Lee arpus who I hope is on
this meeting is I'll be happy to answer
any questions but the technical
scientific things I think should be uh
answered by him if he's on the
meeting yes he representative
Pon yes sir uh he is
uh on on the
meeting and uh he does look to testify
uh so you're saying that he is that he
would be best any technical questions
sir so all right I'm gonna open the uh
testimony to I've open this
to questioning by the the uh members of
the committee yourself uh is there
anyone on the committee who has
questions of Representative
pearon representative Connor sir uh
representative
Conor you there yes uh thank you
representative Pearson you mentioned
that you had a couple changes that you
made to the previous bill would you mind
outlining what those changes were for
answer and representative Morgan
representative Morgan do you have
question of Representative Pearson I do
one question thank you for taking my
question could you tell me how you came
up with 56,600 gallons please well I do
recall that that number was important it
was brought forth at our group meetings
once again if there is a scientific
reason behind that Mr sarus would know
that not
me thank
you sir no more committee members have
questions there been no uh appears that
there are no other committee committee
representatives and have any questions
uh thank you representative for
your
so I believe she's on the phone I don't
have a name but it's got to be
him uh Mr
Leonard Mr letter
there his phone is on
mute uh if you're there Mr sarus your
does he have to do hit the star
six told that you hit the star
six
St if you have a jade Grim strategic
be no that's not on the
there got uh last 3 991 phone number
on allowed to talk but on mute right now
your phone is on mute there no
name and there's no carapus on the in
the audience uh was there someone else
sarus we'll try we'll try Mr sarus later
we have to go Mr chairman this is
representative Pearson if I may yes he
the last four digits of his two phone
numbers are
6113 and
0546 should either of those appear it's
likely to be Mr sarus 546 just showed up
thank
you
sarus he phone is still on mute 546 your
phone 546 is on mute okay here he is
he's good he's good you there Mr
SAR yeah I'm sorry I was trying to
connect through the
um Zoom meeting but I'm on my phone now
are we set to go uh yes what the
question all right first of all your
name uh the town you're
from who do you represent
the time you wish to speak speak
slowly I say turn your video on but you
have no video
so
yours good morning my name is Leonard
sarus I live in the town of Hamstead New
Hampshire and I'm representing um Mark
Bill
yes
by way of background let me introduce
myself I'm a licensed professional
engineer in the state of New Hampshire
and a registered professional hydr
hydrologist in groundwater with the
American Institute of
hydrology I've been actively
participating in these fields for 45
years most often working for or
representing
industry in instances where conditions
warrant I have also represented the
Public House Bill
235 addresses gaps and our current
regulations for new community Wells that
will pump up to
57,600 gallons per day in summary here
is what the bill will provide and
similar to uh representative Pearson I'd
like to start with reading from a letter
that commissioner Scott prepared in
support of a very similar Bill we
brought forward to this committee last
year the letter
States this bill would authorize the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services to establish criteria within
the administrative rules for new small
community water supply Wells to ensure
that if these Wells cause an adverse
impact to nearby private water supply
Wells
nhdes can require the owner to perform
an investigation and
mitigation why is this important the
commissioner goes on to say and this is
from his letter small community water
supply Wells are not subject to
requirements to demonstrate that before
using the well no adverse impacts to
surrounding water users or resources
will occur currently nhdes does not have
authority to require that a small
community water supply well applicant
owner mitigate potential adverse impacts
to private water supply wells in the
event that such impacts
occur this bill will address that
Gap to add some perspective New
Hampshire's groundwater protection act
prohibits 11
specific adverse impacts from a new
community well pumping 40 gallons per
minute it provides none for a well
pumping
39 this bill will provide some
protection the second aspect this bill
addresses is one involving Community
notification when a new small community
well is being
proposed it will require that the party
pursuing a new well provide the same
documents being provided to the dees to
the affected communities to be clear
these will be the same documents already
being provided to the
dees nothing
more one might ask do the people of New
Hampshire need this protection in
thinking through this question please
consider the following first New
Hampshire's population is inre inreasing
and with it water demand causing greater
stress on our
aquifers in September 20120 the
conquered monitor published an article
quoting Dees stating that over 4,000 new
wells are being installed in New
Hampshire each
year second water use Trends are
increasing for example from lawn
irrigation causing greater stress on our
aquifers that same conquered
monitor article also discusses this
aspect now I'd like to read again from
commissioner Scott's letter I believe
it's similar to what uh representative
Pearson had
shared the increasing density of
development within the state and the use
of small community water supply systems
at subdivisions to increase Land
Development increases the likelihood for
these impacts what he's speaking to
there is these adverse
impacts third New Hampshire is
experiencing more severe drought which
brings another type of significant
aquafers last year's drought impacts
demonstrated how severe this can
be taken together this legislation makes
sense to allow Contin development of our
groundwater resources in a responsible
manner while protecting residents with
their own
Wells thank you and I'd be pleased now
to answer questions already posed and
questions thank you is there any are
there any
committee uh representative gsky thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
call in the latest letter that we've
gotten from the uh from the commissioner
of
Dees uh the letter is closed with
says an alternative alternative more
streamlined approach for addressing
potential impacts to other water users
was considered in HB 1347 of the 2020
legislative session how does this
particular Bill HB 235 we have in front
anybody thank you for asking that
question one thing that we changed with
this bill is that the uh the bill
offered last year uh was focused on
causing adverse impacts solely to
private individual Wells um this bill um
was expanded to include similar adverse
impacts to public water supply Wells
that is providing water to communities
and um providing or posing similar
adverse impacts to multiple unit Wells
that might be a a small uh duplex or
apartment building so I think in essence
what we said is safely providing water
to the residents in New Hampshire should
not be differentiated from a private
well uh to any other resident by adding
these other two categories and these by
the way come um directly out of the
existing statute the groundwater
protection
act so just a further explanation or or
clarification so we've increased uh the
coverage is basically what you're saying
is that
correct that is correct we included um
additional Wells providing water to our
residents okay thank you any uh other
questions MERS members here members
behind the screen do you have any
witness there are no one's got their
representative Spang did you have a
[Music]
question she she's talking she's not on
mute so I don't
know representative Spang you we can't
talking we heard a bang but sounds like
unplug I haven't had a problem with it
so good you're good don't
touch we got you we got you now okay got
you plugged in okay yes um I I have a
make clear statements are for executive
sessions uh well it's a testimony but uh
we are you testifying or are you
questioning the witness can't be I'm
testifying all right we're good
allow well first let us uh let us thank
you let us finish with
pres if it's more efficient I can make
this statement during exec session let's
like finish the present
witness and then you I'll recognize you
to testify if you will so wish we we'll
it uh is there any other questions
for Mr
thank you very much I'm sure you have
Cheryl in the audience that wishes All
I'm gonna recognize representative Spang
representative Spang you wish to testify
thank you very much Mr chairman um I was
the chair of the large groundwater uh
study commission uh in
1998 and uh it actually lasted for six
years so it was a very very
comprehensive study commission and well
represented um of various interests uh
we did an incredible amount of work that
actually came up with a large
groundwater withdrawal uh rules that now
stand in our statutes um we are under
great pressure from um from the USA
Springs development uh to do some what
seemed like highly
controversial uh regulations
at the end of the the commission we
decided that uh we had gone as far as we
could in terms of uh regulating the
large groundwater com um perm uh permits
but that there was out outstanding
problem and potentially a very large
problem with the cumulative impact of
the smaller
groundwater uh
withdrawals and as uh the the
commissioner of Dees says these can be
substantial um if you have say a
subdivision or a proliferation of
subdivisions it can really add up and we
we were um sad that we did not have the
opportunity to address this as well um I
am I'm also saddened that we keep
bringing forward um very
critical measures that need to be
undertaken to protect the uh the public
and the environment and Dees has to
repeatedly say yes it's really good it's
really important but we don't have the
resources to do it um so I think that in
this instance we have a clear uh example
of what we expect will be happening
increasingly and which was for seen by
our our large groundwater commission uh
in 98 and now it is beginning to come to
pass and it it with our increasing
droughts it's becoming even more
critical um I think that we should pass
this bill and um and ask Dees to tighten
their belts and do what they can to get
done thank you is there any questions
for the
committee no sir thank you very much
representative Cheryl
Davis we do have Brandon K on the list
first okay he's on the list one question
uh one statement to the chair to uh uh
representative Pearson and rep
representative
sarus uh there's a mention of several uh
letters and Communications we are not we
are not in possession of those if you
could send them to the
committee and also
cist we would like to
have a chair a copy of your uh testimony
for the sent to the committee uh the
K opposition an opposition to the bill
you want to give guidance y Mr Ken
you'll give your
name the town you rep the town you're
from whom you're represent the amount of
time you wish to speak please speak
slowly and if you can turn your video
on Mr
K are you
there yes yes chairman can you hear me
uh yes we can all right thank you
chairman members of the committee I'm
Brandon Kernan I'm the administrator of
the drinking water and groundwater
Bureau at the Department of
Environmental
Services um I hope to speak for two two
today
so I'm sorry Flor is yours thank you so
the department does not support House
Bill 235 um right now we currently at
the department have authority to approve
um and review applications for new
sources of water for Community water
systems and there's a two-tiered
approach right now we have what we call
the large groundwater withdrawals which
exceeds that volume you heard earlier
57,600 57,600 gallons a day or 40
gallons a minute if you pump all day
long and those are typically large
withdrawals for municipalities um to
support their water system and there's a
lot of work that goes on with those
large withdrawals lots of testing it by
Statute it almost takes at least two
years to complete and it can be a couple
hundred, in some settings to for an
applicant to get through that permitting
process and I would invite you to reach
out to some of the large municipalities
to ask about their
experience um that work also has to be
done under the oversight of licensed
professionals um geologists or Engineers
with the right
qualifications the other tier is small
groundwater withdrawals which is what
we're talking about today and that's
less than 5
57,600 gallons a day and often but not
always those are for really small
subdivisions like Standalone housing
developments and and so they have to
develop a water system and they don't
need a lot of water so they do a small
withdrawal um the work can be completed
right now by water system operators well
well
drillers water well contractors and also
liced professionals if people want to do
that um House Bill 235 would
substantially change that small
community well sighting process which is
pretty streamlined right now and we
require substantial testing compared to
what you do now which is just a couple
days of testing in the field you have to
do several weeks if you were to go
forward with requirements of
235 um it also requires that there be a
couple public notification periods and
that Dees staff respond in writing to
public
comments um we expose we opposed Bill
primarily because it's just not
necessary based on our experience and we
haven't seen these small withdrawals
cause impacts the impacts you heard
about earlier had to do with the
replacement well for large withdrawals
which was addressed last session through
a bill that passed house bill um 1252
which now requires more public
involvement and impact assessment for
larg placement
Wells um last session we supported the
concept of a of a bill that had a
similar intent but it was quite a bit
different actually um house bill um
1347 that bill just said Dees could
develop rules to ensure small
withdrawals don't cause impacts to
essentially other residential Wells um
out out in the environment this bill is
quite a bit different where in addition
to the public comment periods we also um
would have to assess the replenishment
rate of an aquafer which is something
that requires a lot more work um you
would have to have licensed
professionals um this bill's this bill
is very explicit on the level of work
that has to be done and so while we
supported the concept of the bill last
session admitting last session just like
this session we can't show the need for
it at this time this bill just goes a
lot further than the previous Bill did
and if you compare the two bills you'll
see the citations and statutes at the
level of work um that that is required
by this bill that may not be necessary
in many settings where these Wells are
being sided where there aren't a lot of
competing water
users um if it is um decided that we're
going to move forward with this bill I
would just recommend we put a fiscal
note together um to assess the cost the
dees staff for administering the
requirements the communities and the
customers of Water Systems to of the
requirements in this bill and thank you
questions I chair has one question maybe
it's
uh what what is the difference for for
large groundwater withdrawals
57,000
Etc uh what's the difference of for
uh Wells of say 50,000 each and getting
100,000 out of them and not having to
bother going through LGE
groundw is that
allowable is that a
reasonable
refence thank you for the question um is
that actually issue was addressed by the
groundwater commission that
representative Spang spoke of earlier
and that people were trying to do that
originally citing Wells at 39 gallons a
minute to get around this big permitting
process we have and so RSA 45C was
amended many years ago to block that and
basically um has a language well or well
cited out a property or place of
business so you now add up the multiple
Wells to determine what threshold you
are large or small withdrawals so that
that cannot occur anymore but it was an
issue
initially thank you are there any
questions have representative Smith uh
question is she she's on mute s you're
representative representative Smith
mute okay I'm here um thank you Mr Karan
for taking my question um the bill last
year which Dees was not opposed to um is
as you say quite a bit different than
the bill we now have before us and um
representative Pearson the prime sponsor
uh cited uh an example of why he
introduced the bills a person um people
in Hamstead who lost power or lost water
uh because a a uh a larger well was put
in nearby
will will the bill 23 5 as I before us
now help them any more than the one
1347 I would say it's a it's a different
issue that well that caused those
impacts was a replacement large
withdrawal which was addressed under
legislation that did pass and is now in
law last year it was House Bill 1252
which stipulates how that type of well
would be replaced in the future to
assess impacts so that that well was not
a new small community well which is
being discussed today so in a lot of
ways that Hamstead scenario that one
specific scenario which was very rare um
has been addressed and is not it would
not be affected by this bill in that
type of scenario followup Mr chair or a
followup yes
um so who would this help if it was
work this spill would help help nearby
residential well owners um that could
potentially be be impacted by new small
community well that there would have to
be a a proactive assessment and maybe an
ongoing assessment to ensure they're not
being dewatered by a new small community
water supply well so that's who could
potentially help that being said we
can't come up with a lot of examples
where we have had adverse impacts and
needed this authority to address them so
that's kind of the missing piece here
while the concept is good we can't show
the need and then there's costs
associated with this work as well that
need to be
addressed thank
you answer your
question yes thank you representative
Grassi representative
Grassi yes yes Mr chairman thank you um
Mr turnon um I'm concerned about housing
cost and one of the things that I'm
looking at here is that a lot of times
we're able to reduce housing cost by
reduc the consumption of land instead of
having two acre lots you do a
conservation subdivision where you make
cluster of the lots and have a single
Community well is this going to
basically discourage people from trying
to lower housing costs by using
conservation subdivisions or cluster
subdivisions and basically drive people
back to the two-acre lot with their
everybody having their own well
thank you representative I mean in the
20 years of at the department I'm
certainly aware of instances where
people looked at our permitting
requirements for large groundwater
withdrawals and decided to put in a
bunch of residential Wells instead of
develop a public water system and so yes
they had the larger Lots I can't say
that's going to be the norm but I'm
certainly aware that that's happened and
one of the downsides to that is that the
residential Wells aren't I'm not saying
they should be regulated but they're not
necessarily required to be tested and
meet standards and so you're also moving
people away from regulated Community
water systems that have water quality
that meets
standards thank you and representative
Kelly sir representative Kelly for a
question thank you Mr chairman uh Mr
kernin thank you for being here um my
question is could you just give a quick
definition of what a large withdrawal
replacement well is just so I can
understand the
difference sure it's when the statute
was passed for large groundwater
withdrawals in 1998 it was only for new
withdrawals going forward um
but the it was important though that and
the legislature included this that they
initially Exempted um replacement Wells
um for those Wells that were constructed
before 1998 because you want systems to
invest in their infrastructure and and
not be um not discouraged from replacing
an inefficient well with a new one and
so so they they did exempt them but as I
talked about new requirements put into
place that when they are constructed
that we do more testing include public
involvement to ensure those pre-1998
withdrawals that are being replace now
look at impacts um when we're appr when
we're approving them and that the public
or municipalities be notified of the
replacement well so if there are
concerns they can reconcile hey that's a
new activity and this is a new
complaint thank you
K just is this
CH uh
we large Wells and small Wells is really
an issue of the amount of that there's
that magic number of
57,000 whatever gallons
per gallons per hour I think it is Gall
per day isn't there's a isn't that the
differentiation between a large
well of a small
well it it is and that number is sort of
a relic from the early 90s when
Community Wells first were had
regulations in New Hampshire for how
they would be developed um again for the
smaller Wells there were a more
streamlined approach for proving them to
make mainly just looking at water
quality in the well sighting um from
those Wells and the larger Wells really
looking at the aquifer as a whole
because a larger well would have more
impacts on a regional water resources
than a a small withdrawal and so the
rules are broken out at that threshold
just because typically unus pic
Portsmith or Rochester wouldn't develop
a well less than 40 gallons a minute or
57,600 gallons a day and so it was kind
of a consensus number back in the early
90s that was carried forward in the late
90s when large groundwater withdrawal
legislation was passed and while it's
not a magical number that impacts can or
can't occur on either side of that
number it has worked really well based
on you know our experience since 1998 it
seems to be a reasonable number and that
number was something the groundwater
commission certainly kicked around
plenty and I think we had consensus to
leave it as is by the time the
work chairman one question yes um Mr
Kernan the uh the last speaker mentioned
that you know the new hampster is
getting additional 4,000 Wells a year
that the use of water on an individual
commercial level was increased at the
same time that you have more drought and
that the the community density is
increasing uh he cited those all as
reasons for this bill um just to confirm
that you believe that that those all
those reasons are not uh strong enough
to to Merit the bill and the cost of uh
over well it's certainly true that more
Wells are being installed Statewide um
but there's also other things happening
in Southern New Hampshire where some of
these small Wells are going offline
because marac river water from
Manchester is being extended down there
and so while there is increased stress
on groundw in some places there's been
decreased in other places certainly as
time goes on and development occurs and
new wells are put near other Wells you
could see more interference and impacts
um but what I'm saying is right now we
can't show that that's a problem that
needs to be addressed and if it's
something we want to get ahead of in
case it might happen somewhere well then
this legislation should pass but then we
need be funded to do the work as well um
you know and also the cost to applicants
and the customers of water systems at
least should be
discussed yeah you know probably a
better way of going about it other than
sort of peace mealing requirements and
legislation is for watersheds aquifers
communities to invest in assessing water
their water supply conditions and having
plans on how water supplies develop in
their towns opposed to sort of this
peace meal One impact out of time
assessment because you know the new
water users and land owners that have
undeveloped property have a right to
reasonably use the water on their
property so it's not the case that even
if laws are passed requiring permits and
for them to obtain that they might not
be able to develop their water supply
they they they would have their legal
rights through common law also to seek
access to their water so we got have to
think about property rights and people's
rights reasonable use of water on their
land even though there's existing users
nearby their their rights are kind of
equal under the reasonable use
Doctrine thanks
sir any any other questions no one has
their hand raised there are no hands
raised there are no hands raised uh
you Cheryl Davis was up Cheryl
Davis raise your hand if you wish to uh
speak is she on the still on the on mute
sir
uh Gerald Davis do you wish to
speak yeah um Cheryl Davis is the name
of Leonard Sis's computer oh okay got it
got it
okay that's that's different all right
uh they're seeing is there any
other people in the audience who wish to
be heard
if
not I
will read in to the
record people on the on the list with
people we already heard from Mr saus Mr
Pearson Pearson Mr K uh in support
and that's that's all we
have I will close the hearing
1040 we're off for
minutes Mr
chair
Mr chair um will we be asking for a
Dees I gu I'm seem to seeing a lot of
yeses why
not uh we will have that will yeah we'll
we want AAL note the year we can get one
in time for the next time we we hear
this which will have to be at our
final uh meeting that we have to
you
for
up
folks
sir
the meeting the
order heing the order is we're
discussing how fill
cables Prime chair recognizes the prime
sponsor of the
bill representative Silber
representative Silber I would ask that
you your name time you
represent
time you uh you wish to speak speak
slowly turn your video
on representative silver are you there I
I am here ah very good wow look like
you're in the library I am and I've read
every one of these
books thank you very much uh present
silver the floor is yours thank you very
much I will try to speak slowly although
that is not normally the pace at which I
speak uh I'm Norman silur uh I represent
belnap District 2 which are the towns of
Guilford and Meredith and I live in
Guilford uh people who know me and my
political philosophy know that I am
generally opposed to increased
regulation but a constituent brought to
my attention
a problem that is Tred to address in
this bill and actions and activities
that were so
egregious that I felt I had no
alternative but to propose this bill and
I've been joined with a number of
co-sponsors mostly reps from the
Southshore of Lake Winn
pasak this deals with a problem with
cabling in Lake winnipauk
but it's probably applicable to cabling
that might happen in other lakes in New
Hampshire the issue is
this when you person someone lives on an
island and they need electric service
telephone service internet any kind of
telecommunication
service they obtain or they have a
company obtained for them a water
crossing permit to allow the laying of a
cable on the lake bottom from the
mainland to the island or perhaps from
an adjacent Island where they can tap in
to their Island and that's fine they get
a you know they get a permit and they do
that the problems happen when a cable
goes bad when they call for repairs and
the cable whoever is servicing the
cables comes out and determines that the
cable is
defective rather than trying to pull up
the cable and find where it's bad and
repairing it the practice appears to be
that they simply lay a new cable in its
place and cut off both ends of the old
cable and just let it leave right there
on the bottom of the
lake so these are abandoned cables and
they the problems that they create are
really in two major areas number one is
cont
ination because the cables in many
instances contain substances that may or
may not leech into the water supply
there may be heavy metals there may be
connectors that have heavy metals in
them and things of that sort I'm told I
am not an an expert a scientist in that
regard the other aspect is the
interference with boating caused by
these abandoned cables because what
happens
is over the years
cables are abandoned and it creates a
spaghetti effect on the lake bottom of
all these abandoned cables so when a
boater and they're not marked of course
there's no marking on the surface to
show you where these are so when a
boater goes to an area where there may
be this spaghetti on the floor of the
lake and they try to Anchor they throw
their anchor over and the anchor cannot
bite into the lake Bottom because it
gets Tangled Up in all of these this
spaghetti now we step back for a moment
and assume that you are doing some
renovation in your home and you're
replacing some wiring and you're taking
out some
cables and would anyone think it would
be permissible Behavior to take the old
cables and take them over to the lake
and just dump them into the lake well
that would be ridiculous that's you know
the lake Lakes are not our dumps we rely
on the lakes for recreation and in some
instances for water and so this is just
terrible behavior and what this B and I
talked to Dees about this and I said
well can't you do something about this
and they said well we give these water
crossing permits but we really don't
have any enforcement mechanism for these
abandoned cables it requires new
legislation voila now you have the
proposed HB
269 and what it says is essentially if
anyone is abandoning a cable because
they're replacing it or for any reason
they got to take it out they're not
going to just drop it on the lake bottom
and if they don't there are Financial
penalties involved so there's no
Financial note there's no Financial
impact on the government on the local
government or the state government the
only financial impact is on the
companies that are doing this or the
perhaps the homeowners that are doing
this that are basically dumping stuff
into our Lake Bottom so we're trying
this is as I said brought to my
attention by a constituent who is a
major factor in the marine industries in
the south shore of Lake winaki but uh
you know this is not confined as I said
to Simply Lake winaki although it's the
biggest lake with the most islands and
the most cabling involved and the most
spaghetti on the lake bottom so we're
not seeking to have anybody go back and
you know do a big cleanup that's that's
a great project for some volunteer
organization all we're saying is going
forward when you abandon a cable in the
future because you're replacing it you
got to take it out you don't just dump
it on the lake bottom and that's
basically it and I'll be happy to take
any
questions any questions
by have one up stand
by uh representative Connor sir uh
representative Connor for a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
representative my question is justo
simple when someone puts a cable in or
has it put in is there any
identification on it so would there be a
way to know whose CA um abandoned cables
that is way above my pay grade but I
simply don't know I I do not
know I I would assume that well I I
can't I really can't assume I don't I
don't the answer is I don't know I'm
sorry okay thank
you representative post sir
representative post for a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative um I wondered where's
the enforcement on this I mean how are
people going to be aware that uh
homeowners um say they you know just
move in and um they go to lay a cable
how are they going to really know about
this this bill and how is it going to be
enforced I think the enforcement is
through the companies that are licensed
to do these installations and the one
and and through the application process
where they apply for water crossing
permits from Dees they would then
presumably get an information sheet that
says hey if you abandon a cable you got
out thank
you there any other representative Cohen
sir representative Cohen for a
question yes thank you for taking my
question would you know are the typical
cost of laying cable and how much more
it adds to that cost of removing and
abandoned
cable I do not know that answer I don't
know the answer to that question it's a
good question it seems to me
that I'm you know I'm not a I'm not a
scientist and I'm not a cable person but
when they lay a cable it looks like they
start from the mainland and they have a
boat or a a u uh you know some sort of
uh floating apparatus that then rolls
out the cable from the mainland to the
um to the island and when they have the
they at at the island end when they're
doing their hookup and they're doing
their cutting and they cut the cable to
be abandoned they just grab it and
should be able to just roll it back up
as they move back to the mainland which
seemed to me as a lay person to be a
fairly simple process of course there's
a cost involved at least the time
involved by the Personnel to do
it just uh just for the representative
edif okay we do have
someone who from the uh New England
cable and Telecommunications Association
following to testify in opposition to
the bill so that that person may be able
question
other no one no other hands
raiser I'm sorry represent Smith
question thank you uh this thank you for
taking my question representative um
this may not
be under the purview of this bill but I
have been hearing stories
of something causing people to get
shocks when they touch their dock when
they're in the water so when you refer
to these as un aband abandoned cables
are they pretty much unhooked from
everything unplugged so that they
wouldn't be producing any electric
current do you know that my
understanding is that when they abandon
a cable they cut it from both ends the
mainland end and the island end so it
would be unlikely that they would leave
an energized cable they connected to in
some way to give a shock on a dock but
you know I guess any
possible okay thank
you is there any other
[Music]
rais thank
you silver
for Testimony thank you for hearing
me next witness
is uh Laura
Wester the England table Dev
Communications
Association and you you've heard my uh
represent speak slow speak loud and
slowly video you can and video if you
can
can you hear me Mr chair yes we can
yours excuse me I'm so I apologize I
think I lost my internet connection for
a moment can you hear me yes thank you
thank you good morning my my name is
Mora Weston I appreciate the opportunity
to be heard this morning I'm speaking to
you today on behalf of the New England
cable and Telecommunications Association
our members include Atlantic Broadband
Charter and Comcast which are some of
New Hampshire's leading Broadband
providers we collectively serve over
450,000 customers in more than4
communities in New
Hampshire
um not to supports measures to protect
the natural world around us and
certainly have a desire to conserve
precious natural resources especially
here in New Hampshire um to that end our
members do take steps uh to conserve
resources and um to support a green
environment and we've done so with a lot
of private sector and not for-profit
initiatives however I am here to speak
today in opposition to house build 26 9
as written um and urge you to consider
this inexpedient to late inexpedient to
legislate for a few
reasons um first and foremost it it
seems overly Broad and a bit unclear and
ambiguous
um for example um a cable may be
inoperative for a wide variety of
reasons uh of particular concern would
be when a cas C is within its useful
life but a NEC member is no longer
providing a signal on that cable because
the receiving sub subscriber doesn't
currently wish to receive our memb
services um uh think for example of an
instance where one owns a home on an
island they have cable television
internet service they sell their home
someone says no I don't want that
service I'll take my service through
satellite that cable is that cable
considered abandoned um it could very
well be the situation where the next
homeowner or perhaps they decide that
they' prefer to switch back from
satellite to Cable um is that cable
abandoned or not in a day in which
Broadband access and internet access is
so important to us all um it would be
unfortunate for our members to incur
tremendous cost to remove cable that
still is within its useful life um when
it could be used uh again for those
valuable services at some point in the
not too distant future so we raise sort
of the the breadth and ambiguity of this
for your
consideration I am I'm afraid I cannot
address the specific issue of cost in
answer to the representative's question
but I am happy to follow up with my
clients to um address that issue for you
and provide more
information uh we also believe that
there could be some unintended
consequences in terms of environmental
impacts and I understand the sponsor's
goal but with some of these cables that
have been there for quite some time
Earth and debris have settled around it
um you know it is it is uh sediment and
debris have accumulated on or around
cabling unearthing that may have
unintended consequences and actually
frustrate the purpose of the
bill
lastly um the the um Provisions seem
punitive overly punitive to us
specifically for the reason that some of
our members actually may not know if
there are abandoned cables um on the
lake floor this is the result of um
decades worth of Acquisitions within our
industry and um you know if somebody
receives the permit well they may well
know but there is also the the situation
where you know through acquisition we
may not know what is there and would
think that um the provisions would be
overly punitive in that case so with
that I'll close my remarks we are
willing to to work uh with the sponsor
and the committee going forward and we
really do appreciate your attention to
you
questions representative poster
representative post for
question thank you Mr chair um I have a
question um a two-part question one is
um
uh
tomorrow
uh do you have any instances where you
already go in there and take out uh old
cables I am not aware to tell you the
truth in my conversations with our
clients um we have one member who serves
one small island in Lake
winaki um so I I don't know the answer
to your question but in term terms of
the the breadth of application of this
it is um I'm not going to say it's a
small impact but I'm going to say it's
limited circumstances in terms of our
membership but I'm happy to ask that
question of that uh particular member as
to if they've ever removed um an
underwater
cable Mr chair may I do a
followup follow yes so my other question
to that is um would pulling these cables
um have to be coordinated with um fish
spawning schedules and things like that
because if you pull that out it's going
to disrupt the the floor
um it's our it's our belief that that
really is part of the unintended
consequences of the bill um there could
be tremendous environmental impact by
actually digging these up and and
removing them I can imagine
that would have to be done in
coordination you know with the with the
state um I don't know the specifics of
the laws around removal but we are
concerned about those unintended
consequences thank you thank you
representative Kelly sir representative
Kelly for a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
M Weston for being here today um so I
just have some questions about uh the
logistics of this when a member uh on an
Island wants to add a service from one
of your members do they uh is that
installation cost passed along directly
to that homeowner or is it um does is it
member um let me see if I can answer
your question this way and you can tell
me if I need to follow up with more
specifics um generally speaking when our
members build out an area to provide
cable television and Internet service
it's a decision that our member company
has made that they want to invest in
that area and they bear the cost of that
and um it's a business
decision if there is an instance however
where we've only Built out to a certain
point but then an individual say lives
you know two and a half miles out out on
a point say and this our service our
buildout hasn't reached them then the
cost could be borne by that person who's
out on that two and a half mile you know
long road or could be an investment that
we choose to split with that individual
but I think in terms of the island that
I know we have built out I believe that
company does that help answer your
question
absolutely um Mr chairman just a quick
could um
so miss Wesson so my next question would
be do you does your do your members
charge customers for fees associated
with the cancellation of service
currently do they like if a member
cancels service do they have to incur
certain fees associated with closing
so
that answer your question yeah thank you
Miss Weston thank
you anyone else for a
question uh representative Mayville sir
representative Mayville for a question
thank you for the opportunity to ask the
question um so I'm you're alluding to
something that I want to clear up do
your member electric companies do your
member telecommunication companies each
use a different type or a kind of cable
for their particular company so that if
perhaps a resident went from Verizon to
Comcast and then back to Verizon that
they would need two separate cables to
use Verizon versus Comcast because that
to me seems like that would be
inhibiting competition if that is indeed
the case and that it could you know we
be talking about something a little
different
here sure I'm happy to try to respond to
that so our member companies are cable
companies that provide video and
internet services um home security
systems over those Fiber Optic
Cables um it that is a different
infrastructure than say uh an electrical
provider I could not speak to their
infrastructure or even um you know I
don't Consolidated Communications for
example which may or may not provide a
landline service to to the particular
islands that I'm referencing I I don't
know who the other providers are as per
Verizon um they are a wireless provider
and so that is an entirely different
type of um infrastructure you know
Wireless Towers um cellular access I
mean I don't so to to answer your
question I mean I'm just speaking to my
client uh position and the
infrastructure that they deploy and
um we we have our own cables and our own
infrastructure and it is not shared
among a variety of providers for example
you can't provide electricity and
wireless Services over that fiber optic
cable that we would deploy does that
help um yeah but Verizon does have fiber
optic cables and they do provide
Broadband services to you know maybe
different states here yes they do they
do in they do in many states uh I'm not
aware of what services they provide on
the islands in winaki thank you
questions so there are no no hands
raised being no more questions thank you
very much for your for your testimony
thank you for the
opportunity is there
anyone else in the audience wishes to
testify
statement I'm rather
concerned somewhat
deted Mr chair yes I see Captain dun
Le's in the a in the audience I don't
know if he would have anything to add to
this from Marine Patrol I don't
know it's the closest thing that I don't
see
anyone he's not on my he's not on the
list of being in
the he's ready talk right Captain
dby sorry
to Dron you into this but uh could you
speak could you uh help the committee
with
the with the states position on this
Bill yes thank you Mr chairman if you
can you all hear me okay yes thank you
uh honorable members of the committee I
am
Tim how about
now you're back thank you Mr chair
honorable members of the committee my
name is Tim Dunley and I am the captain
of the State Police Marine Patrol unit
um I uh I thought I had registered in
opposition of this bill this morning but
I did lose internet connection myself
and and therefore it may not have
registered I'll briefly just speak to
our concerns uh and that is specifically
to the Penalty section of this proposed
Bill where it is the division of State
Police or local law enforcement who
would assess the
fines um from from that perspective we
have concern as we are not familiar with
those um utilities that may have
received permits from other uh state
agencies and therefore who we would hold
responsible for us may be very difficult
the reason for that is is many of our
Islands when using Lake wiip pasak as an
example run one trunk line to the island
itself particularly if there's more than
one residents on the island and then
there are typical utility polls down the
center of the island where where
person's Camp May then be fed uh
whatever service may exist on that
island so to whom we would hold
responsible other than the utility
itself um we we would struggle from an
enforcement perspective furthermore we
would not have any knowledge not not
having known who has received these
permits typically our contact with any
cabling uh is what uh representative
Silber mentioned uh I can think on a
very rare occasion maybe one every
couple of years where we'll get a call
for boat who has hooked its anchor on
one of these cables uh we have no
knowledge of what kind of cable it is uh
we have no knowledge of of whether it's
live or or not and so uh just from an
ignorance as an agency with cabling and
that sort of thing uh I would suggest
perhaps uh an administrative enforcement
of this statute uh should it be passed
be considered uh from a criminal
perspective uh it would be very
difficult for our agency to enforce and
and I would suspect any local law
enforcement agency other than perhaps a
code enforcement
officer so uh I'm happy to answer any
questions uh provide you with any
information that I may know offhand
regarding cabling on the lake uh and
make myself available to
those represent post has a question sir
uh representative post for
question thank you Mr chairman and um uh
Captain duny Could you um speak to um
the freshwater habitat if you're pulling
the these
cables I I will do my best only as a as
a sportsman representative uh I do know
that in the springtime certainly the
nesting of of particular bass species
and so forth is a critical time uh for
their nesting uh fishing game would be
the agency and a biologist would be the
agency to get that very accurate
information but but I know that we see
Seasons um for fishing uh around those
nesting times and it is typically in the
thank you very
much any other questions by by the
committee so representative Kelly
representative Kelly for
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Captain Dunley being here today um
just a question I've seen the number 274
habitable Islands on wab basaki do we
have any idea how many residences on
those islands or how many actual
residents live out
there we do not have that number um but
I will tell you that it is um you know
probably in the low thousands uh we have
several big islands that have several
hundred residents on them and and
there's an example of where the the
whole island is serviced likely by one
trunk line um to serve all those
residents there are numerous islands
where there's just one individual
resident on there uh and certainly with
the advancement of of Technology cell
phone and and satellite uh perhaps a lot
of those cables are now obsolete if they
ever were installed uh a lot of these
islands preserved the The Rustic nature
and and so several of those islands
never received those services to begin
speak thank you Captain D love
you is there any other Representatives
questions or any question any one from
the audience wishes to
speak there are no hands raised there
are no hands
raised read
the the list of what people I have I
heard representative
silver Mara Weston I have Sparky
vinsky parked official representative
district 7
in
support
himself
Josh Pella elected official 33 in
position
hary
official
support Ronald
cedan member of the public in opposition
and David lad member of the public in
support that's what I have uh seeing
nothing business before committee on
this bill I will
hear think we
are first
our Bess I guess we will we will Cy we
will be back at
1:00
for
actually maybe we got a chance to do
some maybe we have a chance to do some
executive
sessions
uh
let let me let me open an executive
session
bills representative Smith you had
uh some
amendments thank you yes um let me find
it
House Bill 193 on Timber
trespass we heard this bill last
up uh which I'm trying to
find uh which on
line two of the
bill
the bill reads no person shall
negligently cut fell destroy injure
carry away or cause to be cut fell
destroyed injured or carried away and
then in the second section uh the
criminal penalty the same or is
removed uh so that it does not confuse
uh actually I should probably let
representative harb answer you know
describe that because he was the one who
was concerned that this was confusing um
but anyway basically one ore was removed
from the bill or two ores uh but in the
same place in two different sections of
the bill if that makes sense and so I
would move
Amendment that's the problem I can't
it's
0157 I would second that Mr chairman
representative
057 all right
[Music]
all
right ex this is the this will be the
executive
session on House
Bill
and do I have a
motion do I have a do I have a motion to
uh motion the motion is uh well do I
have a motion on House Bill
193 representative
Smith recognize you for a
motion so we want it on the amendment or
on the bill we already did the amendment
is that true I guess it should be to uh
uh ought to pass with Amendment okay so
I move ought to pass as amended on House
Bill 193 and the amendment as we already
said was house uh was right well will
there be to they'll be we make the
motion for un to pass as am as amended
I'll then bring forth the amendment we
will vote on the
amendment and then we will vote on the
pass am I'll second her motion Mr
chairman representative
harb representative har uh okay
uh representative Str your motion is to
a to pass Bill 193 a pass as amended yes
that is my motion do I have a second as
the second is from representative har
correct am all right we have an
amendment vote on the amendment
first
and the amendment
h57 hotel right right I I will give you
Amendment
015h and you you uh you have spoken to
the to the amendment
any questions representative
poster representative post
representative post you have a question
on the
amend I have a question on how to find
it to print it and read it oh I sent it
to everyone yesterday at around 3:47
pm thank you I'll look for
that yeah that that's my fault I should
have can we can
uh can someone share this can Brad can
you share the screen are you the
host i w I am the host however I can
allow everybody to share their screen um
I do not I was not sent the amendment
unfortunately oh
okay you have it
up you should be able to share your
screens
now chair is trying to see if he can
share it he has it up on his
screen thankfully he knows much more
perfect so this is this is
representative maville I'm sorry I had a
comment I was keeping notes our last
session and um perhaps I erroneously
recollected or wrote the wrong thing but
um regarding representativ harbs um
addendums I believe he had said and this
may be just word smithing that he had
said to add the word negligently after
or you know or before caused to be cut
so that it was no person sell
negligently cut blah blah blah or
negligently caused to be cut and the
same with the second that no person so
recklessly cut LA or recklessly caused
to be cut that that's what I had in my
notes and perhaps I am not recollecting
correctly
representative harb could you answer
that yes I can thank you if the chair
would let me speak
yeah thank you m Mr chair thank you um I
had I had made that comment
representative but that was if you
didn't delete the or I am perfectly
comfortable with the amendment and I
thank representative Smith for bringing
it Forward by deleting the or in
paragraph one and subparagraph 21 and 1
one um it then connects together with
the negligently that appears in like the
fourth word in each of the sentences so
I am fine with it now as an attorney I
have no difficulty in ascertaining that
negligent applies to the whole Clause
not just the first
yeah oh yeah any other questions on the
amendment there are no questions no
questions on the
amendment on amendment
number
amend
RO and representative gunky
representative gunky yes representative
gunky yes representative
ghouls yes
yes representative G says yes
representative Horgan
yes representative organ says yes
representative parp
yes representative parp says yes
representative Kon representative Kon
says yes representative BR says yes
representative
Dodge
yes representative Dodge says yes
representative hary bull says yes
representative hey representative hey
says yes representative key says yes
representative mville yes representative
Mayville says yes representative post
representative post says yes
representative post says yes repres
representative Smith yes representative
Smith representative Smith says yes
representative Spang representative
Spang votes
yes representative Spang votes yes
representative grassy representative
um representative grassie votes yes
representative
goling of go y I'm unmuted I I vote
Yes representative goling votes yes
representative Cohen yes representative
Cohen votes yes representative
Connors yes representative Connor votes
yes yes representative
Kelly
yes representative Kelly votes yes
representative Moran
gay0
to
amended anyone any more
discussion being none report please call
the
r um representative
gunky gunky votes yes representative
gunky votes yes representative
gouls yes representative gold votes yes
representative organ
yes representative Morgan votes yes
representative harp yes representative
harp votes yes representative pronon
votes
yes representative prayon votes yes
representative Dodge
yes representative Dodge votes yes
representative Harvey buia votes yes
representative
hey yes he votes yes representa mville
representative vot post votes
yes representative postes post votes yes
representative Smith representative
Smith votes
yes representative Smith votes yes
representative Spang representative
Spang votes
yes yes representative gr representative
grassy votes
yes representative grassy votes yes
representative go
representative goling votes
yes gotl votes yes representative Cohen
yes representative con votes yes
representative Connors representative
Connors is yes representative Connor
votes yes representative
Bale
yes representative Bale votes yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Kelly votes yes representan
yes representative Moran votes yes
representative rul representative Rula
votes
yes here's the bill
passes hasn't
been
uh for
uh first of all for consent calendar
S no objection the
Set
uh or the committee
report I guess got
report I can do
no
it's that being said that we are done
with
that my screen again if people don't
have
it chair will
recognize represent representative Smith
to talk about House Bill
99 thank you Mr chair um House Bill 99
uh as you recall from the public
hearing
uh was the exact same bill that was
introduced last year and in committee
last year we determined that it needed
some
amendments because
it and so this amendment is pretty much
a rewrite of the bill as it was passed
out of resources and passed on the
consent calendar of the house in 2020
and the differences are that there is an
exemption on this on the uh bottom of
page one of the
amendment uh that uh Captain Dunley
spoke to us about about giving a an
exemption to any local state or federal
government agency or agency subra
contractors that need to be doing um
non-recreational execution of their
duties such as work related to law
enforcement bridge and road work
Pollution Control the protection of Fish
and Wildlife or environment studies so
that was inserted in the bill and the
other thing was it the original Bill
um let me find it
included any land that you could see and
you know any land owner that could see
the uh seasonal float could complain
about it and I'm that's not really clear
but that was kind of it so this means
this bill pretty much now as amended
says you cannot put a seasonal platform
except in front of your
problem does that make
sense anyone
have
any uh any questions basically as I
understand it your basically this
amendment just
makes the the bill the house bill
99 uh makes
it uh as it was passed by this committee
basically right is that correct
representative yes and Mr chair I just
found the uh wording in the bill as it
was introduced to us last week uh at the
bottom of page one of the original bill
of House Bill 99 not the amendment it
says any person installing an anchored
seasonal platform shall demonstrate to
the satisfaction of the director that
the placement of such anchored seasonal
plat form does not obstruct any
shorefront properties's view of the body
of water in which the anchored season
platform is to be
installed and so that was deleted out of
this amendment because of the testimony
we heard that if I had a seasonal
platform that was one of those big ones
with the slide someone could see it a
half a mile away from their property and
complained that they could see it and
therefore it shouldn't be allowed so
basically since water is in the public
trust it was only it had to be put in
front of your property and you couldn't
uh complain if it was property Three
Doors
[Applause]
Down any
Smith
is
right I see no hands raised all right uh
all right the motion that I will accept
is the uh is well we don't have a motion
motion uh if
we if if there's a Rel reluctance to uh
to put forth a motion don't worry I
previous I checked the
uh the house the uh
house uh record from March 20 of March 6
of
2020 uh on the predecessor to this bill
which is call House Bill 609 Rel de
seion of platforms on public Waters of
the state and that's an a the
pass it seems said it was the the the
report was written by Andrew wulo so he
will write the next one he will so
should write it again
any I'll accept a
motion of the pass
with with Amendment and I will write the
BL it makes anybody feel better
representative post has a question
representative post for a
question I was going to suggest that I
would make a motion to accept this as
amended this B as
amended have a motion by a motion by by
representative post to uh for ought to
99 there a second the motion second by
representative bky
203h uh is there any discussion on the
amendment which replaces
the well well first of all will do I
have a motion to accept the
amendment actually I
think it's been a while that uh
the amendment the amendment was on to
pass as amended but Al I'll accept the
motion on the just on the amendment to
have for uh Amendment 20 203h so
representative
post be
anyone our representative post I'll make
a motion to accept the amendment of
hb99 Mo motion is there a
second second second by representative
ksky uh on the motion to
adopt
the3 any there any discussion seeing
call Representative gunky
yes representative gunski says yes
representative
R yes
wol says yes representative Morgan
yes Corgan says yes representative car
yes representative car says yes
representative Katon says
yes says yes representative Dodge
yes Dodge says yes bullus says yes
representative hey says yes
representative Heely says yes
representative mayel yes
nville says yes representative post
representative post says
yes says yes representative Smith
yes says yes representative Spang
yes says yeses grassy representative
grassy says yes grassy says yes
representative
dling
yes says yes representative
Cohen
yes represent says yes no one says yes
no one says yes representative Connor
representative Connor says
yes Connor says yes representative
Bale
yes B says yes representative Kelly
yes representative Kelly says yes
representative
Moran
yes on the motion
for to accept to
adap up to pass as amended for House
Bill
99 no for the
discussion
will please follow the RO yes
representative gunky representative
gunky is yes yes representative
gold gold says
yes says yes representative Morgan yes
par
we lost him how do we lose him where'd
yeses har says yes representative Kon
says
yes says yes representative Dodge yes
Dodge says yes repres hary bullia says
yes representative hey hey yes hey yes
representative mville mville yes V yes
representative post representative post
says
yes V says yes representative Smith
yes says yes representative Spang
yes Spang says yes representative
grassie representative grassy says
yes grassy says yes representative
goling yes goling says yes
representative Cohen
yesen says yes representative Connors
yes Connor says yes representative
Bale
yes Bale says yes representative
Moran
yes
consent
99 the pass as amended be on the consent
calendar and the will be written by me
uh I think that's it for we can take a
break uh we will recess
o'
we're
off
attend
18 I don't know how many want to
[Music]
speak
for
[Music]
ready
um so I'm not taking roll
up okay going open the hearing on House
Bill
271 relative to
standards F and polyal substances
ppas drinking water and ambient Brown
sponsor is represent M the grand sponsor
Ron
representative
she good afternoon can everybody hear me
uh yes just you know some ground rules
uh you who you are what you who District
you represent how long you're to talk
mic okay thank you chairman Rulo and
members of the resources Recreation and
development committee um for the record
my name is representative Rosemary rung
I represent marac which is Hillsboro 21
for those who are returning members of
this committee this bill is the same as
last year's HB
5037 which as amended passed unanimously
in this committee and passed in the
house on the consent calendar
unfortunately it was laid on the covid
table in the Senate so thus it returns
to you today nothing in this bill has
changed from HB 50 1537 is passed its
intent is to ensure New Hampshire
statutes use consistent nomenclature for
the class of chemicals known as pasas
per and poly floral alkal
substances aligning New Hampshire
terminology of this chemical class with
national International and scientific
reference so you will see in HB 271
occurrences of PFC which stand for
perorin chemicals are replaced with
pasas and I want to quote from the US
EPA perorin chemicals is a term that
some scientists use to refer to the
group of toxic chemicals that include
pfoa and pfos and other per and
polyfloral alkal substances
organizations that have used the
abbreviation pfcs referring to perorin
chemicals include EP a US Centers for
Disease Control and prevention and the
UN Organization for economic cooperation
and development EPA is now trying to use
perr and polyfloral alkal substances
pfas rather than perorin chemicals pfcs
consistently to collectively describe
pfoa pfos and other chemicals in this
group so additionally on on the bill on
page two line three language is removed
that limits the definition of pasas to
the 18 compounds listed in epa's method
537 over 5,000 now exist and new pasas
are invented constantly their definition
should be based on the general molecular
structure not which ones were used in an
analytical method which could very well
become obsolete with technological
advancements
but any PFC the hazard and the safety is
determined by scientific studies that
follow accepted uh procedures so you'll
see in the bill in section six it's
outlined what past may be qualified for
regulation but just referring to them as
past does not indicate any Hazard that
has to be determined um through
generally accepted scientifical
scientific principles applied to study
um I want to thank you very much for
your attention I would be happy to take
any of your
questions is there any questions
by
committee questions by members of the
committee behind the screen I see no
questions uh I do have
one question
myself looking
at
as
versus 1537 which is its predecessor
Bill
uh in uh in the 271 you have
several uh you have one two you have
four for
carbon mention and those are not
mentioned in the
uh in the the the prior
bill
they there a there just a a paragraph
describing
it uh could you
just if you can speak to that appreciate
that yes thank thank you for your
question chairman Rulo um those four uh
pfoa uh chemicals that are listed um in
271 are already in statute when the
original bill was filed those mcls had
not been um passed so there was no need
to include that language in the original
in this bill because it uh there the uh
485 colon 16 it already gone into
question representative Smith
mute thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question representative
I just wanted to confirm that um we do
have you did on on page two it does or
page one it talks about the four that
are now regulated are there any others
regulated by Dees any other posos no not
sir
thank you very much representative okay
committee
have
in
I can you hear me uh yes just before you
start uh we okay where you're uh where
you from your town you represent the
town you live in uh who you
represent and how much you know no long
plan to speak and also just keep back
from the microphone enough so that you
come through reasonably well
video let me give that a try um thank
you chairman Rulo uh members of the
committee my name is Steve Rosado uh I
uh representing the American chemistry
Virginia all right the the floor is the
yours are you there let me unmute there
we are okay sorry about that all right
so um thank you for the opportunity to
provide comments on House Bill 271
related to perr and poly floral alkal
substances or pasas ACC takes a neutral
position on the bill but would like to
offer a couple of suggested amendments
to better focus the state's attention
and resources our comments concern the
def expansive definition of pasas in
section three of the bill and the
criteria for determining which P may be
of interest while the state has been
conducting stack testing for some time
it is important to recognize that that
EPA has yet to develop a valid
analytical technique for measuring p in
air EPA has however developed validated
methods for measuring a total of 29
pasas in drinking water to ensure
accuracy and reproducibility of the data
collected we encourage the committee to
limit the focus of hr5 271 to those
substances for which analytical
techniques have been validated we
understand however that there is concern
about limiting the department to a
couple dozen substances as an
alternative we suggest a definition for
pasas that focuses on those substances
likely to be found in water excluding
refrigerant gases volatile liquids and
polymers the definition is derived from
materials developed by the interstate
research and Technology Council of the
environmental Council of the states in
which the state is an active
participant in addition we encourage the
committee to revise the requirements in
paragraph six of section three
concerning which pasas to be considered
under the section the bill currently
sets the bar rather Low by allowing for
consideration of pasas for which a
single study is available suggesting
potential health effects we recommend
that the language be revised to require
that any studies to be considered be
published in a scientific journal that
is subject to peer review the standard
generally applied by USA and other
authoritative bodies thank you I would
be happy to answer any
questions there any
committee um
post representative post for a
question thank you Mr chair for taking
my question um Mr Roto have you
submitted any testimony with um
everything you spoke about in writing I
inbox apologies I I we have not but I I
know that we will be submitting it very
shortly thank
you representative Cohen sir uh
representative Cohen through four
question thank you for taking my
question can you please tell me what
your knowledge of your Association in a
12 month period perhaps the last 12
months or something close how many new
derivatives of past have been released
to the to the commercial industry
whether it's a brand new compound or a
modification of an existing something
that's called P could you give me an
idea to what the number is in a 12-
month period please
well thank you good good question
representative Cohen and and I I can't
give you a definitive answer I I can
give you sort of a a general uh a
general response um all new chemistries
whether perorin or otherwise must be
must go to Federal EPA for review uh
prior to going on the market um I do not
know I we can certainly check and get
back to you with any products that have
been submitted to EPA or that have been
uh released to the market uh within the
last year um the legislation passed uh
by the US Congress at the end of last
year put some restrictions on new
chemistries so it may be that they're
having been very many over the last few
months uh but we can certainly check and
and and get back to you all along Please
Mr
chairperson uh for a followup yes
followup please
yes follow yeah so Mr R based in your
knowledge then uh you said there's no
you know you can find out how many new
pfest but what about an existing pfest
that just changed a little bit so the
it's derivative of pest you give me a
ballpark in a year what that might
be I any any change to the to the
structure uh would trigger a new
chemical uh requirement approval from EP
PA I I it it's I don't think you can
tweak you know slightly tweak the
chemical structure and still consider it
the same chemical um so I think it would
be the same answer that it would it
would have to go through EPA to uh for
approval but let me double check that
and and and we're C certainly can get
back to you thank you for your question
thank you for your
answer
Kelly representa PO is that satisfi is
that is that your extent of your
question that is the extent of my
question thank you very
much representative Kelly for a question
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
being here Mr rotto um I just uh Mr
rotto could you maybe just give us a
little uh overview of what the EPA is
evaluating when a chemical is submitting
um are they sub are they evaluating it's
you know environmental impact only or
are they looking at certain C just the
water impact or impact in the water what
goes through that process it it it and
thank you for your question um it it
runs the it can run the full gamut um it
it is depends a bit on the particular
chemistry um but you know EPA will look
at health and environmental uh effects
it'll also look at you know how uh how
it would be used you know what the
likelihood for exposure is to workers to
uh you know to to the environment also
what the potential for relief pces are
from that use based on that it will then
ask for data either you know data that's
already been developed or and May in in
and often uh request uh you know new
studies to provide new data so it it
depends a bit on the individual
chemistry but it you know it does look
at the full health and environmental
impacts you know water air Etc or can
things
does that answer your question yes yes
thank you thank you Mr
zto uh any other questions by members of
the committee represent Moran had his
hand up and it's down now so I don't
know if he has question Mr chairman um
I'm sorry I I the the speaker um wh whom
represent
chry am chemistry Council all right uh
Mr chairman yes I do have a question all
right for a question yes uh thank you
for being here can you tell me who you
represent in uh the state of New
Hampshire in the state of New Hampshire
I do not have a list of our membership
uh in the state apologies again uh we
can track that down and get back to you
yeah if you could send that to us that
would be
appreciative Mr chairman can I have a
follow-up question or follow yeah when
you send uh if can you send uh your list
of membership and and you can also
identify if any of them are involved in
any lawsuits uh regarding um uh uh the
Water uh PFS pfas um that would be also
very helpful if you know if any of your
members are in litigation with the
state yeah I we'll do our best I mean we
don't you know we generally don't track
the individual litigation that comp that
our members are involved in but
certainly we are aware of of litigation
in New Hampshire and and can let you
know if if we know of it um it but it
may not be
comprehensive thank you
other I see no other questions sir no
other questions from committee thank you
very much for your
that is the only people who signed up to
testify you got to be kidding me in the
now we have Mindy
mesner Mindy
mler
uh you come there all right uh couple
things state your name town uh whom you
represent how long you plan to speak uh
be
uh this sit back from the microphone and
feedback that's about
it great can you hear me FL is yours yep
okay great sorry about that I did sign
up in advance this morning but um not
sure why it didn't show up on your list
but I am Mindy Mesmer former state
representative for Ryan Newcastle um a
registered professional geologist in the
state of New Hampshire and uh am
registering in support of this bill
today thank you for hearing my testimony
uh I was the author of the original bill
that amended RSA 485116 e and at that
time uh pfcs was a regular uh jar
uh for referring to these class of
chemicals and since then uh as rep
representative Rong stated the EPA and
other organizations have renamed this
class of chemicals including atsdr which
I'll send um in my testimony to you in
written testimony after this um uh
hearing uh atsdr has um clarified really
clearly in their fact um pages that pfcs
were renamed as pest because it was
confusing to many people because past
can also be pfcs can also be termed per
fluorocarbons which are a set of
different chemicals which are known to
be very um powerful greenhouse gases so
they kind of uh decided that past was a
more relevant term to refer to these
chemicals so I support the um
modifications to RSA 16e uh in House
Bill 271 I also wanted to um uh talk
about Lin on page two lines 3 through
seven the changes which were made which
I also agree with um these refer to an
old set of um analytical methods
originally developed when these
chemicals emerged as concerns and even
on the epa's website uh they still talk
about this reference to this method but
it's only um referenced as a historical
um reference for people to to work with
but the they refer to the newer much
updated methods um an EPA does update
their methods from time to time in 2018
this first modification was made 2020
and actually just a few weeks ago three
weeks ago EPA also issued some U
modifications to these methods so I
think it's entirely appropriate to
remove these lines from the bill because
we don't want to refer in our rules to
Old um to Old references and I just
wanted to also uh just clarify in
section on page three line 11 in section
six um the prior um person who testified
talked about one study this section says
at least one study that is peer-reviewed
could be used by the state Dees to
determine appropriate um levels in New
Hampshire not just one so I think that's
appropriate um at least one study used
and it just sort of sets a lower bar for
them uh to use the science to determine
what chemicals are appropriate to set
levels for um also there are there is an
EPA website that talks about sort of
summarizes all of the methods that are
currently acceptable to EPA they do have
one acceptable method for testing air
emissions is OT
m-45 which uh is an air emission meth a
method to analyze air emissions for up
to 50 pfast chemicals so just um in
support of this bill it's just I view
this as a sort of a house cleaning Bill
to update our rules and sort of make
them more um uh updatable for from now
on so be happy to take any uh questions
from
anybody there any questions from members
committee that yeah Mr chairman I I have
one question previous testimony
suggested an amendment that would limit
the testing to only water and not air
what would your be opinion about that
Amendment
well this section was added um I think
it's lines e through e and on um because
we do have um an issue here in the state
of New Hampshire with Airborne releases
from uh an industry in marac so I I
would not want to limit the ability of
our state um agencies to uh determine
what's appropriate and safe for exposure
um we know that in the in the case of
marac that the air emissions CA caused
uh drinking water levels to exceed what
we feel is safe and what the dees has
determined to be safe in the state of
New Hampshire so I uh would trust them
to be able to come up with appropriate
standards in the future um so I would
say I I disagree with that amendment to
to the
bill okay thank
you any other questions MERS of the
committee sir ion no questions no
questions all right thank you very much
you are there any
other requests to be heard I see none
sir there no no more testimony and close
the
hearing excuse me before I close the
hearing read in not the total number not
the every name on this list
but uh we have a remote
testimony uh one is one is neutral two
support now I will close the hear and we
hearing
don't
you're off you all
right
hearing House
Bill 115 relative to wake
surfing
and chair calls the prime sponsor of the
bill representative
Smith thank you Mr chair good afternoon
committee
members for the record I'm Suzanne Smith
I represent the towns of Plymouth Hein
and holderness in Grafton County
District 8 and I am here uh as the prime
sponsor of the bill I was also the chair
of the commission to study wake boats
which uh worked for a year or more uh
to learn more about wake boats
and everything about them and so this
bill came out of that
commission it was voted on by the
commission uh the the language of the
bill was voted on by the commission
which was brought to us by the
department of safety and all members
agreed that this was a uh a bill that
they could agree on the bill defines
wake
surfing and it makes those that wake
surf subject to the same safety
standards as water skiers and wake
borders who are towed behind
boats that includes uh requiring wake
surface to be wearing a PFD having a
spotter on the boat in case they fall
and uh a few other minor um
things so it also specifies the type of
boat that you may use if you are wake
surfing the big difference between wake
surfing and wake boarding or water
skiing is that you only use a very short
toe rope to get up and then once you are
up you drop the rope and you are
effectively surfing behind the boat
within 5 to 15 feet of the back of the
boat and so the reason that the the only
boat that you may wake surf behind is a
wake boat or a ballast boat um is
because the engines of those boats are
situated so that the energy of the motor
goes down not out the back and there is
no danger of the Wake surfer being
caught in a prop as could happen with an
inboard or an outboard motor I went to a
website C uh that asked what boat can
you wake surf behind and it basically
said you couldn't wake surf behind
inboard boats including direct drives
and V
drives No wait yeah it's said the only
you couldn't do you couldn't wake surf
behind just your basic outboard or
inboard motor because you needed one
where the engine and the Drive Unit are
placed inside the boat and the propeller
comes out under the hle and in front of
the transom so I mean it's a bill that
everyone agreed on it is all about
safety and I know there is someone who
is else who is going to speak on this
who can tell you a lot more about them
who was also on the commission but I
urge you to uh support this bill and
vote ought to pass and if you have any
committee I see no questions there are
no no questions thank you very
much thank you
representative
like is yours thank you Mr chair and
thank you members of the resources
committee I do uh served on the Wake boo
commission uh with representative Smith
and uh this was agreed upon by all
members of the
commission uh in in fact actually the
water sports industry uh individuals
that were that were being represented on
the commission uh would understand the
sport better than all of us they all
agreed also that this was the uh that
this
legislation uh should should be passed
so I just wanted to add that information
onto the the testimony and as as
representative Smith had said I know we
have an individual that's supposed to be
speaking that'll give us more
information about the boat specifically
that is used for for uh the WG surfing
uh sport so that's uh that's all I have
to add anybody has any questions I want
have to add answer for
you any questions by any members of the
committee I see no questions uh who is
the person who the person that you
mum are you available things are onl
streen okay Mr mum ask you to speak uh
give give your name the town whom you
represent time you need to speak I ask
that you speak uh relatively slowly and
turn your video on if
possible gum floor is
yours you
there I am here and unfortunately I
can't see a video tab
on my
screen continue something wrong with
this
stupid um good afternoon Mr chairman and
honorable members of the committee uh
for the record my name is Peter mallum
I'm the owner of mum's boat house here
in Epsom on Northwood Lake uh we're a
small family business that was started
by my grandmother and grandfather over
70 years ago and we're a full service
Boat and Marine
dealership I also happen to serve as the
new president of the New Hampshire
Marine trades Association the New
Hampshire Marine trades Association is a
trade Association of marine industry
businesses committed to recreational
boating in New Hampshire and we support
boating safety as a tenant of our
organization and serve as stewards of
our lakes in order to protect the
environment and the health and the
waterways
um I also participated in HP 137 I was
appointed by Governor
sonunu um and uh through that
Association I was brought forward as a
representative through the Northwood
Lake Watershed Association another
protection Group which I'm happy to be a
member of uh you heard in prior
testimony that the commission spent many
months looking at issues related to wake
Sports and wake vots and I'm open to any
questions or the field any that you may
have the suggestion of improving current
laws relative to wake surfing was
important it came from the Marine Patrol
and was met with un unanimous support
this is a common sense Bill we want
folks to enjoy water sport safely hb15
is another way to accomplish that and we
ask for your
support that's it for my opening
statement if you have any questions I'd
feel any
questions
I see no questions no questions you said
is this is your statement correct yes it
is Sir and representative post does have
question thank you for taking my
question and thank you um Mr mum for
your testimony today um I have a couple
questions and so there might be follow
up um is there going to be a penalty for
wake surfing behind Bo boats that uh are
not a wake vat um or are we taking wake
entirely uh leg legislation was uh
defined to be specific and to narrow the
definition of the type of vessel that
could be safely wake surfed behind uh so
you'll find wake surfing in that uh in
that
script um chair could I do a followup to
that follow
up so if there are individuals um wake
surfing off of the back of a regular
boat um that is not defined for you to
wake surf on would there be a
penalty and who would enforce it and
would there be a financial component to
do
that uh that's an excellent question one
that would be geared towards New
Hampshire Marine Patrol they they helped
craft uh the language to help Define
what would be allowed uh for example a a
small outboard engine that would be
operated via a tiller maybe a fishing
style boat would be a great example of a
type of vessel that would not be allowed
uh by
understanding and and the what the
penalty phase would be I'm not 100% sure
that's been defined whether it would be
invi uh involved with any monetary
penalty I don't I haven't been advised
of that either but it's the it's it's
speaks to the style of the hull that can
work and it most certainly wouldn't be a
Drive
thank you Mr M any other
questions sir I see no further questions
nother questions thank you
Mr my pleasure thank
have
Lakes says
you're have him on the list Tom BR is
not on the list there is another
representative
from
Davis I I have Michelle Davis
okay Michelle Davis are
off hi can you hear me yes but before
you
start good name what the town the you
represent the time you're going to the
amount of time you're going to speak
speak slowly turn the video on if
possible
and the floor is yours thank you chair
and and members of the the house
resources Recreation and development
committee my name is Michelle Davis I am
the advocacy program coordinator at New
Hampshire Lakes we did submit testimony
regarding uh House Bill
115 and um I do believe Tom is caught up
in another hearing right now so um I
will just Echo the fact that this was a
consensus piece of legislation as
Representatives on the Wake booat study
commission we support
adding wake surfing to existing safety
legislation um as a as a means to have
it comply and fall in line with other
questions I see no questions sir see no
you
all
right I don't know is is Sil yes yes
okay just Mr Silver you
uh wor signed up to TW but you know you
you withdrawn that uh yes I've withdrawn
that and I withdrawn my objection to the
legislation okay thank you very
much
uh I see no one
else
on the list of people no one else
speak c d sir oh c
d see he's not on the list Captain
Dy can you Enlighten us on some few
things than I'd be happy to thank you Mr
chair again I I uh I thought I had
registered this morning but perhaps some
connection problems uh didn't didn't
reflect that my name is Tim dun leevy uh
with the state police Marine Patrol unit
uh I thank you uh honorable members of
the resources committee for hearing my
testimony today on behalf of the Marine
Patrol and the department of safety we
support this legislation We we played an
active role at the commission level with
these recommendations
and uh briefly I will say that this
simply closes the gap on several laws
that are already in place for those
engaged in towed water sports water
skiing knee boarding and so forth it
requires the wearing of a life jacket by
that uh wake Surfer it requires uh the
boat to have an observer on board in the
event that there is a problem or a
fallen W wake
Surfer it prohibits this use uh this
activity after Sunset and during the
hours of Darkness like water skiing and
it does go beyond just the safety issues
as it as it already applies to water ski
and that it does restrict the types of
boats that you can use to engage in wake
surfing you've heard the testimony by
those before me as to the dangers of the
types of propulsion uh that do exist and
they're sometimes attempted to use for
Wake serving I would be happy to answer
any questions that any of you may have
questions
post
Kelly representative Kelly for
question this Captain dun Levy thank you
for being here again um my my question
I'm new could you just give me an idea
of how many Marine Patrol officers the
state has um and how many lakes we they
they
Patrol we routinely Patrol about 200
Lakes 200 to 275 on a regular basis not
all of them see an officer every day
certainly our larger lakes and our Coast
sea officers every day uh including day
and night shifts uh we have
approximately 40 officers on our roster
right now um made up primarily of
seasonal uh officers
uh there are there are eight
full-time uh year- round positions uh
three of whom are assigned to a Homeland
Coast I answer your question Y correct
yep thank
you post representative post yes so so
this would be the same question I asked
of the um last uh person to testify um
what would the penalty be um how would
it be enforced and uh what is the
financial component of
that uh the the penalty would fall This
falls under the water skiing statutes
and therefore the penalties are
violation um the fine schedule set for
this type of violation is $86 in change
uh forgive me I don't know exactly the
the the change um from an enforcement
perspective this is a a routine type
enforcement action that that an officer
would take should they observe this type
of
violation um we we see these routinely
uh it's part of our regular Patrol shift
as a state trooper would enforce uh uh
speed on the highway or or Lane
violations this is a is a uh an OBS an a
violation that would typically be
observed by the officer and addressed
right
away there would be no Financial
component um as far as uh a cost to the
agency as it would be part of the the
office's uh daily
certainly representative Dodge had his
hand up but I don't know whether he
representative Dodge hand up I I did but
actually representative post covered my
questions thank you representative
Mayville representative Mayville for a
question yes a question please captain
and this is just a minor clarification
from someone who was wake boarding about
30 years ago so the difference between a
wake Surfer and a wake border is that
you may use the same type of a
conveyance but a wake border is attached
to a tow rope and a wake Surfer is not
is that
correct that is correct your wake Surfer
is is using a traditional toe line that
a water skier would would use and is
constantly uh being towed by the boat uh
the Wake Surfer will start on a very
short rope similar to like a barefoot
water skier right behind the vessel once
the boat achieves the uh preferred type
of
wake the Wake Surfer lets go of that
rope and is propelled by the motion of
the
Wake so there is no connection at that
point
does that answer your
question yes it just wasn't quite clear
in the bill when it was talking about
wake surfing and I would have preferred
to see it like a it is you're not
attached to the boat it just makes the
whole piece clearer to me but thank
you representative Kelly sir
representative Kelly for a
question yeah just another question
about enforcement uh Captain dun do you
does the public often submit evidence
like let's say if someone uh was seen
without a life jacket while water water
skiing and they took a picture and sent
it to your office would there be any
followup on that or is it is it only
when there it's enforced by a
patrolman um that would be an extremely
unusual circumstance there we do receive
complaints from the public about water
skiers with no observers or Towing too
many and we will dispatch an officer if
we have one on that body of water to
that area to see if they observe the
violation um to take enforcement action
on on uh call from the member of the
public for this type of activity
and and ult have it ultimately result in
enforcement action when the officer
didn't observe it that doesn't
happen if that if that's your question
yes it is thank you okay representative
post representative post for
question thank you for taking my
question um uh Mr D
would there be uh the same uh standard
for Barefoot skiing as the Wake Surfer
since um it has to do about the boat and
from uh no because the barefoot water
skiers are still attached and towed uh
typically a barefoot water skier is is
um
the the accepted length of a tow rope
for all these other water sports is
approximately 75 ft some barefoot water
skars will will be towed by a boom that
sticks out from the side of the boat but
not behind it so those safety concerns
don't exist with with Barefoot
activities May I do a followup followup
can you explain the safety concern of a
uh person wake surfing off a boat and
and what the real real problem is
there the safety
problem well certainly um I think the
the need for a life jacket speaks for
itself and I don't I don't mean that uh
sarcastically uh along with observers
these are all common laws that have been
on the books uh in our state for a long
time and are are on Most states uh books
if you will for these types of water
sport
activities um and then obviously for the
time after after Sunset if a person
should fall after dark and they are
separated from their towboat they're
subject to the other boating traffic
that would have no way of seeing them so
these are these are routine accepted
safety measures that protect the the
skier or the Wake Surfer or the uh knee
boarder uh from from becoming more
seriously injured uh while engaged in
this
activity may I do a followup a follow up
h but we were specifically talking about
the Wake Surfer boat being able to only
do that with a wake Surfer
boat so I was asking about what is the
safety concern that you could only use a
wake Surfer
boat there are there are several
considerations first and foremost the
propeller and the engine on uh the boats
that would be prohibited from this
activity subject the the surfer who is
in very close proximity to the back of
the boat from from making contact with
that propeller a boat that is designed
for wake surfing specifically has its
Drive its prop beneath the boat and
forward of the transom and the transom
is just another term for the back of the
boat so the the Wake Surfer would have
to go underwater and forward underneath
the back of the boat before it would
ever be um able to make contact with
that
propeller traditional uh boats if you
will not manufactured with this type of
propulsion in mind have those propellers
right at the back of the boat where
them may I have another followup
follow um so there are some ski boats
that do have their propellers forward so
we're only defining it as a wake Surfer
boat would a boat like that fall into
being a w surer
bo uh I I would defer to some of the the
experts in in the manufacturing of them
but it is my experience that your
typical uh production skib boat only is
probably not going to create the type of
environment that the Wake surface are
looking for for their
activity um what they may do which is a
concern and another reason uh that this
legislation has brought forward is they
do sell
aftermarket uh bags they call them Bast
bags where people will fill these bags
with water when they're on board their
boat creating more wake thus creating
excuse me more weight thus creating a
larger wake unfortunately what's not
considered there is the capacity of that
boat to handle that extra weight and
that shifting cargo which is obviously
us thank you restive Dodge
sir representative Dodge for a question
yes I have a question thank you Mr chair
um it's a quick one um about how many
actual injuries related to these safety
concerns do you see say per year or per
season here in New
Hampshire uh it depends on specifically
the activity wake surfing right now
we're not seeing that many other than
injuries that result from
Falls um we have not thankfully had uh
routine uh injuries as a result of
propellers um we we do see uh you know
near drownings and and those types of of
activities by tow water sports often and
it's those life jackets that that
certainly make a difference with those
uh but it's more personal injuries as a
result of Falls where we see these these
our accident numbers uh being related to
Toad
you sir I see no further questions thank
you uh there no further
questions thank you very much
and thank you thank
you now there's no one
else anyone else in the audience who
looking to
testify I see no one in the audience
looking to testify being no one else in
Clos I'll open the hearing for to exec
executive
session on mil Bill
115 you hearing
open to this discussion I'm sorry Mr
chairman someone did chime in after you
closed it I don't know if you wanna who
[Music]
mallum
yes new hire Marine trade Association
testimony all right we opening the
uh the executive
session uh any comments by uh any
concerns comments by the uh by members
committee yes so just one com I've been
water skinned for 40 years and this just
makes complete sense to me as a as a
longtime water
ski
any any other comments any other
questions by members of the committee
representative Smith sir representative
Smith yeah Mr chair I was just going to
um if if representative post still had
questions about the type of boat and
engine uh motor uh that Peter mcallum
could answer that question that was um
why I was trying to get you before you
closed the hearing but I didn't make it
in time
thank answer a specific question I will
allow Mr I will allow a question yeah
unless unless representative post is all
set no I I would appreciate
that who's on Mr
Mel yes I'd be I'd be happy to make an
effort to provide some clarification
about
propulsion uh representative post you
question
representative post sorry took me a
second um yeah so I wanted to know the
difference between the Wake Surfer boat
and a uh ski boat that has their
propellers underneath the boat because I
I don't see the difference between the
two in in making the legislation that
apply to one rather than the
other yeah most certainly it it's a
confusing world that I I live in as a
myriad of combustion choices and
propulsion choices but in an effort to
break it down um this this H Bill 115
was purely put forward for Wake surer
safety uh one element is is obviously
the life jacket the PFD but the biggest
element you're testify now I would like
you to answer the question what's the
difference between wake bolt wake
surf wake Sur in other words what answer
the question so we can get back into
executive
session so a boat propulsion type that
could be appropriate for wake surfing is
specifically an inboard boat a jet Boo
or forward-facing Stern Drive propulsion
system propulsion system systems that
would potentially injure a wake Surfer
would be specifically an outboard engine
or a stern drive engine non forward
facing that's my
testimony does that answer your question
representative post yes it does thank
you very much and thank you um
representative Smith thank you very
much all right back to the
uh back to the executive session
representative Smith you
question or
concern for the
committee okay is you're appearing on
the you're you're appearing on the on
the screen uh is there anyone else who
wishes
to to
comment about the bill before
us so I see no other comments no no
other comments I'm sorry stand by
representative post representative post
post sorry um I wondered if we could
have an amendment to
clarify the votes in here um how he
talked about it being in board boat jet
boat forward
that have to the executive session to
have that Amendment brought in and hear
it at aure
time so all right uh so you would we ask
I'll ask the rest of the uh committee if
to I just off a minutes I'm sorry Mr
chairman yeah
representative under item seven no
person should operate a motor propelled
by an outboard motor inboard outboard
motor or water jet while a person is way
serving that's I think pretty much what
he
said we have a representative who wants
to bring in will you bring in Amendment
represent
post no I I'll withdraw it okay
representative Smith sir representative
Smith well I was just going to uh read
what the former representative said
about what the rules are about the boat
I mean it you shall not operate by an
outboard inboard outboard or water jet
while a person is wake surfing or in the
wake of such a motorboat unless the the
propulsion system is specifically
designed by the manufacturer for that
activity and
since and so I mean there is no boat
called a wake surfing boat it is a wake
boat or a ballast boat or a towboat that
carries ballast and it can make the
waves for wake surfing and so it I don't
know what an amendment would say that's
all I was going to say I think this
pretty is pretty
clear representative has withdrawn
request representative Cohen sir
representative Cohen for no I took my
hand out representative post withdrew
her request for Amendment so I've taken
this anyone else there are no hands up
Sir there no hands up in that case be
right being no
motion s so make a motion that we
approve the uh House Bill 115 as
written have a motion we I have a second
that
represent excuse me I didn't I don't
know who the people were who made the
motion to
motion okay
you hear
me have you heard me did you hear
representative Smith no I
[Laughter]
didn't made the motion representative
Conor made
the May the second you're a little
you're a little blurry uh Mr chair so
that's why I'm not getting it I don't
think I'll find out I'm I'm hearing the
same thing
thank
you it was so good this morning I know I
know you do a buffer thing yeah is this
is this
better can you hear me now
yes did did you hear
representative did the made the motion
and represent P been
second maybe someone could translate for
you it could be a buffer because it's
been on so
long all right and is there any is there
motion being
none
on up
for House Bill 115
to motion is the
pass please call the
RO yes representative gunky
representative gunky votes yes gunky
votes yes representative G
representative G yes gold yes
representative
Morgan
yes organ votes yes I think uh repr
representative
har
yes har votes yes representative kraton
Katon
yes right votes yes representative Dodge
yes um representative Healey he votes
yes he votes yes representative
mville yes
post representative post votes
yes post votes yes representative
Smith representative Smith votes yes
Smith votes yes representative Spang
Spang votes yes Spang votes yes
representative grassy representative gry
votes
yes gry votes yes representative gotl
yes
yes goling votes yes representative
Cohen yes Cohen votes yes representative
Connors representative Connors votes
Vil
yes mail votes yes representative Kelly
representative Kelly votes yes Kell
votes yes representative Moran yes
representative Ren Zulu yes it's 19 Y
nay
19 19 to1 the motion passes uh is there
a like
the report
Report there doesn't need to be okay uh
can we go for uh consent for consent put
Cal it goes on consent calendar it means
it's voted for it's voted in Mass
to go to the floor that's fine I'm
outnumbered
okay that's not a problem it us to be
the same way and see where I ended up
and 15 minutes
on
she
what
[Music]
for
call
okay
you're
off like to
open open the hearing on House Bill
229 def finding weight
bo uh we have a a lot of people who wish
to
talk we're going to do the best we can
to get them in but I'm going to ask
people to to clear concise
and there's always talking about about
50 people who want to speak 44 44 people
who want to speak and so who have signed
in
so other that will open the I will
request um representative representative
bill the floor is the floor is yours
however realize I'm asking you and
everyone
else
that that we that you
speak for who you are who your name your
name uh where you from
how long you wish to speak and please
speak clearly step back from the
microphone
and clearly by relatively slow if you
can go ahead representative the floor is
yours good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the resource Recreation and
development committee it is an honor and
pleasure to appear before you today my
name is representative John T McDonald
I'm from Cal district 6 which consists
of the community of wolf
bro I'm here to introduce to you today
committee House Bill 229 which provides
a reasonable definition of a wake
booat wake booat means any boat that's
equipped with ballast tanks bags
compartments containers Plumbing or
similar devices or systems that is
designed to alter or enhance the
characteristics of the boat's wake and
and also is known as a ballast boat the
wording of this legislation is
consistent with the proposed definition
by the National Association of State
boating law
administrators this organization known
as nasbla represents a recreational
boting authorities of all 50 states and
US
Territories a wake booat when operated
without its within its attended purposes
is just like any other boat however when
operators fill the Ballance tanks or
compartments
the B creates a much larger wake than
normal this bill comes at the request of
many constituents sure front property
owners fishermen kayakers canist M Boat
Owners dock owners Lake Associations and
many other users of our state's lakes
and ponds some of the shared ideal are
to protect the healthy balance in our
lakes and ponds to promote boting safety
and to prevent damage to personal
property and the erosion of
shorelines this bill is now designated
or intended to be anti- booting
anti-family anti- bus anti-water sport
anti-tourist or other any other anti-
New Hampshire values it is a common
sense bill that would define a type of
boat that has been operating on our
state's lakes and ponds and rivers for
the past several
years education is an important
component in the pursuit of any
recreational activity establish a
definition of a wake booat is the first
step in an educationally directed
program this bill will solidify a
Statewide definition and enhance our
abilities to educate and inform the
general public without a clear and
precise definition there could be a
great deal of confusion with the voting
public and the residents of our
state lastly there may be testimony of
this definition result in the Banning of
or restrictions imposed on Wake boats
under RSA 270 col 11 the commissioner of
safety appears to be granted the
authority to create rules I'm unsure
without legal opinion from State
authorities if such an authority would
apply in this particular case in any
event is my understanding that the
creation of any rules requir the
department of safety to hold public
hearings to receive testimony from all
concerned or interested parties thank
you for your time and consideration
concerning HB
thank you representative are there any
questions of the representative from
committee sure you have one
question representative mville
representative mville for question thank
you Mr chair for the question
representative can you please tell me
how many types of watercraft are defined
RSA to mind again uh possibly Captain
Dunley could be better answer that
question but I believe uh skcraft have
their own little particular section
under a uh definition of particular
design for those particular type of
vessels or
crafts thank
you there any other questions from
committee see on thank you very
much very like representative thank you
Mr
chairman representative Suzanne
Smith thank you Mr chair um I'm Suzanne
Smith I represent the towns of Plymouth
Hein and holderness Newfound Lake and
Squam Lake included in those towns and I
am the former chair of the commission to
study wake
boats and I am supporting House Bill
229 it is one of the things that we
discussed during the commission and to
me defining what a wake booat is seemed
like a reasonable solution unfortunately
all the commission members could not
agree on that and so it was not put in
as a recommendation of the
committee however during the course of
the commission I heard them called
towboats although wak Surfers do not use
a toe rope to enjoy their sport ballast
boats because they take on ballast to
create the large wakes or should they
just be referred to as wake boats and
the committee members even vacillated
between those three names so I'm asking
you to listen to the testimony today and
vote hopefully to pass this bill I will
say that I have received a lot of emails
as you all have and many of
them are treated treating this
definition bill as a ban on Wake boats a
ban on wake surfing and that is
certainly not the case and I'll just
quote I just received or we just
received a letter from the Squam Lakes
Association and they're supporting the
bill and they see it as an effort to
clearly Define wake boats and this
improved definition will allow
stakeholders to have a more refined
conversation about the use regulation
and management of wake boats in New
Hampshire and I couldn't have said
better and I thank you I will not see
time any questions from members of the
committee I have one question stand
by representative Connors representative
Connors for a question thank you Mr
chairman representative Smith I received
a lot of emails as well and if you could
just clarify for me is a typical
motorboat with an outboard engine that
pulls water skar is that considered a
wake booat under this
definition no thank you for your
question and no that is not the case
although during the course of my years
as a legislator where people call and
complain about problems I've heard from
a lot of people about waves on their
lakes and I have no idea if they're
talking about a wake booat or just a
boat that's doing uh pulling a tuber
around in their neighborhood so I think
for that's one reason to Define this so
I can people can learn the
difference thank you very much and
representative gold representa go for a
question yes thank you for taking my
question um what was the uh ratio of
people in favor of this uh explanation
on the commission versus i' say it was
5050 okay thank you it was a very evenly
defined
I'm sorry representative post sir
representative post for a
question thank you Mr chair um um
representative Smith I still find the
definition to be
ambiguous um or ambiguous sorry
um that last bill we did 229 which had
um the definition at the bottom if I can
find it I stuck it somewhere
um no that was
115 where um it
indicated um motorboat propelled by an
outboard motor INB because there are
these boats that skiers um ski on where
like professional skiers people who ski
a lot um in competition where that um
propeller is underneath and I believe
that would fall into the same Cate atory
as and and I think we talked about that
before so I would like to see the
definition include so people can
understand because I think this is very
vague um that we add number seven
this
thank question comment um I did not
write this bill I am a co-sponsor I was
not the prime mover and Shaker behind it
but the definition the you could have
you could ski behind a wake booat but if
you were skiing behind a wake booat you
would not be putting ballast in the bags
you would leave them empty because with
your water skiing you do not want to
have a lot of weight so you know so
that's why they specify here that it is
a boat equipped with ballast tanks bags
compartments containers designed to
alter the the Wake so if you were water
skiing I mean a water ski boat water
skiers do not want to have wake so
regardless of what type of boat it is
it's it they don't use ballast bags on
ski boats although you could take a wake
booat and use it for water skiing by not
filling the ballast bags but it wouldn't
affect what kind of a motor it had and
there may be people can address that
more clearly but that's when I am
goal repr May Bill
sir representative Mayville for a
question thank you Mr chair to
representative Smith did the commission
discuss the um for lack of a better word
the surf bums forums and their
modification of inboard boats to adjust
with um uh modified lead weights and
increased people on the boat to throw
the exact same wave as a ballast
boat we thank you for your question we
did have some discussion of that and
there was discussion about how to
address it in legislation and mostly
because of having to miss meetings
because of covid and hitting our
deadline of June 30th we did not pursue
that but also we couldn't come to a
clear
solution but we were we there was talk
of
banning or you know of of I don't want
to say Banning but regulating um
aftermarket ballast bags or five gallon
buckets filled with water that can roll
around and hurt people in the back of
the boat there was we did have
discussions on
that thank
you question chair I do have a
question
question thank you for clarifying but I
I have to ask one question because
it the question before was if you had
for example an outboard
boat uh you could make that a Ballance
boat or Not by simply adding or taking
away bags or the other things so really
the weight boat is a
configuration not a specific boat is
that is that the way you read this no
that is not the way I sorry but um no
that is not the way I read it
[Music]
um because this just says it's a boat
equipped with the ballast tanks and bags
um I don't it's not my bill I mean I'm
the I'm co-sponsoring the idea of
defining wake boats but I did not write
this bill so I can't comment any further
than that okay ma'am thank
you any other questions so there are no
hands up seeing done thank you very much
by okay go ahead Mr
Gallum before you start your name town
who you
represent the time that you time of your
presentation please speak slowly turn on
your video if you
have uh good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the House resources
Recreation and Development Committee for
the record my name is Peter mcallum my
uh testimony will be slightly over four
minutes I'm the owner of mccallum's Boat
House in epom New Hampshire where we've
sold in service boats for over 70
years additionally I'm the current
president of the New Hampshire Marine
trades Association on behalf of my
customer base my business and my
Association I'm here before you in
229 by way of background I was appointed
by Governor sonunu to serve on HP 137
the study commission which
representative Smith has mentioned we
conducted a comprehensive review of
issues relating to wake BS the
commission included representatives from
a varied group of stakeholders including
voters industry shorefront owners
legislators state agencies and
others the commission met eight times
from September
2019 through June of 2020 it was a
meaningful and productive
Endeavor the commission received
numerous presentations and developed a
21-page final report which might be
terrifically helpful in answering some
questions on how to speak to Bast boats
versus Wake
boats uh HB 137 wake boolt commission
did not recommend defining wake bolts in
statute it has since been made clear
through in-person meetings reading
written comments from supporters of
defining the craft and past experience
involving other type crafts that this is
the first step in an agenda to ban and
or restrict the use of wake bools in New
Hampshire
the passage of HB 229 would devastate
the New Hampshire Marine industry and
severely impact the recreational boating
economy in our state let's speak
directly about our
economy recent data composed by our
industry states that recreational
boating accounts for
$1.6 billion dollar annually in New
Hampshire this economic modeling is
driven from many direct and indirect
sources including over 6600 jobs and
over $270 million in direct retail sales
of new boats engines and
accessories our New Hampshire's boating
industry provides jobs at marinas
provides Revenue at the gas pump the
service industry food tourists lodging
businesses and
more recreational boating is a true
Family Affair and wake boats continue to
lead the industry in growth because of
their popularity and
versatility there simp no better way to
connect multiple generations of families
and friends than a day boating on the
lake and during the most recent pandemic
voting was particularly popular it's
been said that voting saved the summer
for many people in New Hampshire this
past
year let's talk briefly about AIS
because you'll hear a lot about this
topic this afternoon aquatic invasive
species is a concern for all boers
shorefront owners and anyone who loves
New Hampshire
waterways as any Marina operator will
tell you our businesses rely on healthy
lakes and keeping Lakes clean is
critical to a strong boating
economy we learned through the study in
commission uh of HP 137 the truth about
boats all boats get wet we learned that
the droplets of water can contain
microorganisms whether it's a ballast
bag a punch boat heel or transom a
trailer frame a fishing Live Well an
engine compartment a buge the hull of a
kayak or a canoe following the new New
Hampshire clean drain and dry laws for
all power and non-p power boats is
Paramount a decal program that requires
outof State voters to purchase an AIS
decal is a new prog program that's not
been implemented due to the pandemic we
need to allow time for these important
new laws to
work we also learned in the commission
through data provided by the New
Hampshire Lakes lak host program that
less than 5% of wake Vats are
transient even at this minimal risk
concerns about ballast and AIS are real
and manufacturers are currently testing
new systems to improve the technology to
further lower the risk of AIS and both
new built and used field
boats I'd like to quickly speak to
education rather than supporting
government laws that lead to restriction
of use New Hampshire Marine trades along
with our partnership with New Hampshire
Marine Patrol have embarked on an effort
to better educate water sports families
on best
practices this new initiative is called
the Wake responsibly campaign it was
started toward the end of the 2020
voting season and is focused on
promoting that wake boats remain 200
feet away from Shore and object
keeping music at reasonable levels and
minimizing repetitive passes in the same
area of a water body We Believe focusing
on the boat operator should be the pro
approach not focusing on the boat or
product we intend to ramp up this
educational campaign immediately in the
spring in conclusion I believe that the
efforts to Define and restrict a large
number of Voters on New Hampshire
waterways is the wrong message for a
state that boasts such a strong outdoor
economy
education and enforcement of current
laws are the key not bans and
restrictions my business industry and
Association stands ready to work with
all stakeholder holders to resolve these
conflicts I respectfully urge this
committee toine House Bill 229
inexpedient to legislate thank you for
your time and
consideration than
you first of all you went we went way
over your four minutes we won't allow
that again
the then other speaker uh I want to
questions have one
question stand
by Kelly representative Kelly
representative Kelly for a question Mr M
thank you for coming here today um in
your uh testimony you referenced greater
enforcement of current laws um would you
support raising the boting boting
licensing fee
to uh to pay for greater enforcement for
officers added Revenue Al always will
assist with a problem and there's no
question that New Hampshire Marine
Patrol suffers Staffing so I would I
would say that uh if that was one way to
gain revenue our group would be in
support
thank
you representative gusy question thank
you Mr chair uh Mr mcallum you had
mentioned the uh equatic invasive
species can you give us any additional
information as far as are the boat
Builders are they doing anything to to
combat that specific
issue uh and if so could you if they are
could you explain as to what they're
looking at and how that will impact the
these boats on our
waterways sure so for the remaining
five% of the Wake fols that travel from
Lake to Lake in the state the industry
speaks directly to that uh they they are
developing uh patented technology that
could involve a number of mediums to
cure uh number one is increased
filtration as water is brought into the
ballast tank it has a higher level of
filtration to keep uh aquatic invasive
species out uh there's a technology that
involves heat and there's technology
that involves ultr light uh treatments
as well as uh mild bleaching Solutions
so there there's a number of uh
solutions that are on the table
representative
guny on thank you okay I turned
flashlight off no further questions no
much is Tom o'ri newshire Lakes who also
commission all right Tom O'Brien from
New Hampshire Lakes we on the
way Brian uh again name town will you
represent time that you're going to be
onri yes thank you I thank you uh sir
can you hear me okay can hear you fine
thank you Tom O'Brien I'm the president
of New Hampshire Lakes we're a Statewide
membership organization working to
ensure the long-term health of our
Lakes our members of course are almost
all Boat Owners many of whom are
lakefront property owners but not all
uh and we think that wake booting as a
as a sport as a as an activity is
everything that it has been described by
Mr
mallum uh popular to those who do it uh
and certainly important from an economic
standpoint so New Hampshire Lakes is not
seeking to ban wake boating or uh
anything of the like we are strongly in
support of this
bill wake boats when they're operated in
a certain way and please understand that
the whole ballast design um and this
definition by the way as was was was
described by representative McDonald
this is a definition that that voting
law administrators Marine Patrol
agencies across the country have worked
long and hard to come up with so I i' i'
respectfully suggest not modifying that
definition um they bring years and years
of experience to this so the idea here
is that specific boats designed in the
way that this is these described in this
legislation create the largest wave
possible it's a much larger wave than
it's normally used for other toe sports
like
watering it also has a Stern because of
the ballast that is lower in the water
and so there's a different activity
going on
underneath so in addition to the spread
or the Potential Threat to the spreading
of aquatic invasive species when these
boats are operated uh as they're
designed for creating these larger than
normal waves they these waves are
pounding the shorelines we have people
who whose boats and and Moorings and
Hardware are literally getting snapped
off people who can't sit out on their
docks and floats because of the Waves
washing over them uh we're concerned
about shoreline erosion and when they're
operated in Shallow Waters with the
sediment that gets turned up from the
lake bottom and the release of nutrients
from that Lake Bottom sediment is what
contributes to algo blooms and cyano
bacteria
outbreaks when we're talking about
economics I can tell you that when
Winter Harbor up in wolfboro had a cyano
bacteria outbreak about two years ago
our phone started ringing when people
said am I going to be able to rent my
place for the month of July or whatever
the case might be uh and tell my tenants
that they can safely go into Lake wiip
pasak uh we couldn't of course tell them
that so we're we're not trying to ban a
sport we're not trying to ban a boat
we're saying that these boats need to be
operated in such a fashion and not might
be a certain distance from Shore and
frankly there are lakes in New Hampshire
that are working this out as Squam Lakes
alluded to there are some Lakes whose
associations have significant capacity
and they can engage in these Community
conversations
around the appropriate place for these
boats to operate so that they're far
enough from Shore they're in deep enough
water uh and it works so but in order to
do that we do have to Define them uh the
the reality is is that the industry has
pushed back so hard on even this
Prospect of defining him that the
conversation is constantly muddled all
boats cause wakes all boats cause waves
it's all water skiing and that simply
isn't you know isn't the case here we're
talking about a distinct type of boat
designed to create the largest wave
possible and as a result of that when
they're operated in certain places and
in certain ways they're having very
definite impacts both on Lake water
quality and the safety of other boers
and swimmers so we're just looking for a
reasonable path uh towards a a
management approach a management
approach that will include education and
it may uh involve specific setbacks or
water depths
and it's doable we're not proposing any
of that here today we're simply
suggesting that it needs to begin with a
definition of these craft a definition
that has been developed by a nationwide
agency uh task with this work uh and I
can tell you that there are there are a
dozen or more states that we're in
contact with that are wrestling with
this very same thing because these
impacts are being felt throughout the
lakes of of of the country I'm happy to
take any questions question that you may
have thank
O'Brien sir I see no questions you see
no questions thank you very much for
your
testimony thank you sir next is
John he's a vice pres Marine trade
also
ising
joh
Wy raise your hand please he's on he's
on he on okay Mr Mr
Wy your name Town who you
represent uh it's
slowly uh turn on your video if you've
got it uh and give me the time how much
half
so the floor is
yours thank you I'm John Wall-E from
Gilford New Hampshire I'm the general
manager of silver SS Marina I was a
member of the House Bill 137 wake boo
study commission and I'm also the vice
president of the Hampshire Marines
trades Association thank you for
allowing me to talk Mr chairman and
members of the house I'm here to oppose
House Bill 229
um just from conversation just hearing
this now um I like to point out that
wake boats towboats our goal is not to
make the largest wake possible our boats
are versatile where you can water ski
tube wake board wake surf do a multiple
different things of family activities it
is not the goal to create waves to rock
the shoreline erode the shoreline it is
our goal to allow people to recreate
safely and do activities that they s of
choose um H spill 229 includes the term
ballast and if you don't know ballast is
a form of weight and the ballast can do
multiple different things it can improve
the performance of a boat it can improve
the ride of a boat it can improve the
stability of a boat and it can also
manipulate the characteristics of awake
Bast is seen as steel weights concrete
lead and water and these systems can be
installed from the factory by
manufacturers or purchased in
aftermarket stores and online retailers
it's important to point out though that
ballast is also people and Fuel and
boers can ask their passengers to sit on
one side of a boat or better to improve
the ride or change this the shape of a
wake even coolers can be used as a form
of Bast and it's also important to point
out that in this bill it this talk of
underwater equipment and this was
installed as early as the mid 1990s and
this characteristics will shape and
alter wakes both to to increase and
decrease the size of wakes on inboard
skib boats thus adding confusion to the
proposed wake boat
definition my father Mike Wally was a
member of the New Hampshire house
actually a member of this committee
before serving as the deputy speaker of
the house he was a businessman we ran a
power sports dealership that sold
motorcycles cobs and jet skis in the
late 1980s there was a law defined to
Define jet skis as ski craft once that
law was proven and made to a law it
banned
40% of ski Craft on New Hampshire's
navigable Waters in by Statute and by
petition consumer driven Market changes
to these watercraft allowed them that to
broaden the law in doing so renewed
efforts to try and ban these jet skis
was lost in legislature because they
repeatedly figured out that during this
the public lost its rights to public
Waters and Public Access
my father also saw it needed to improve
our voting conditions and he with a
bipartisan group of
legislatur put into law border education
and the safe border program became
effective in May of 2002 prior to that
in 2001 there was
115 accidents on the lakes in 2002 there
was 122 I like to point out that by 2019
with over 96,000 Boer registrations in
the state of New Hampshire just 35
accidents were recorded by the state re
Patrol and reductions were down by
nearly 50% of summons and
also uh excuse me um warnings I implore
you to please oppose House Bill
229 from our information education is
the key restrictions are not the key and
a definition of wake boats will not
prove anything but leading to
restrictions thank you for your
time thank you any questions by members
of the
committee have one stand
much uh representative post
representative post for a
question yes thank you Mr chairman and
um thank you for testifying today Mr
wayy I did not see anything in my inbox
that um regarding your testimony have
you submitted Rootin
testimony
uh the testimony was pached with the uh
letter from the Marine trades
Association but I can make sure to add
him can you hear me I'm still here no no
I I didn't hear the end of that okay I I
can attach my testimony but much of the
testimony was included in a letter from
myself Mr mallum uh through the N Marine
Trad
Association thank you you're welcome
representative Kelly sir representative
Kelly
question thank you Mr Wally for being
here today um S silver SS Marina is a
dealer of Centurion Boats is that
correct this is correct followup
question Mr chairman
follow can you tell the board what the
Centurion Lo uh motto or the uh line
underneath their logo
is I honestly cannot I I think it's
something of the verbage of um great
wakes or or something like that but I
honestly do not know the
verbage okay thank you you're
welcome else any more
questions sir I see no more questions
questions thank you very
much next Mr chair I have Winston Sims
who's another member of the weight Lo
short supporting the bill he has five
minutes okay Mr
Bott
ahead s first of all need name Town yes
uh my name is Winston Sims s i served as
a
member Mr
Sim thank you I name I need the town I
need what you who you represent I need
the uh I need the time and if you PL
would you would like to speak it says
five minutes I would like you to make to
realize that there are many many people
wishing to speak if you could shorten it
it would be appreciate it speak but
however do speak slowly so we can
understand you can hear you and turn on
your video if you have thank you thank
you uh I understand you can hear me now
I can hear you I uh am a resident of
Harrisville New
Hampshire and um have been have served
as a member of the commission on Wake
boats as a
representative of uh Lakes uh with fewer
than 10 with fewer than 1,000
Acres I I want to express appreciation
to John McDonald
uh Suzanne
Smith uh and uh Mr mallum I think that
uh everyone who has spoken has
contributed an important part of the
discussion that took place I'm speaking
very much in favor of the uh uh House
Bill
229 with its
definition uh the only thing I would add
to the definition uh is that uh
following the word
Plumbing um the word pumps also be
included because I think that pumps are
an important part of moving uh water
from uh into tanks or out of
Tanks um I think the discussion this
afternoon has been extremely useful and
I think it points to the usefulness of
uh House Bill
229 by seeking to uh clarify what it is
that's being spoken of in terms of a
wake boo uh it's clear that there are
questions as to what a wake boo is and I
think this serves to uh clarify that I
think the definition as given here
indicates no uh inclination on the part
of anyone to uh support uh wake boats or
to uh prohibit wake
boats and uh so I think that uh the use
I think this um is uh quite useful for
the clarity that it
brings uh thank you very
much any questions by members of the
committee none no questions sir none
much next is Mr Scott
bner uh New Hampshire chapter of the USA
water ski and water sports and he was
also a member of
bner yes can you hear me Mr chair before
you start your name found who do you
represent
the time that you're going to be
speaking speak slowly and turn on your
video if you have thank you the floor is
yours yes thank thank you Mr chair and
and members of the New Hampshire house
resources Recreation and development
committee my name is Scott Boehner I
live in hopkington New Hampshire I also
have waterfront property in Northwood
New Hampshire I'm a volunteer I'm also
an athlete and official
of the State of New Hampshire American
water ski
Association which is under the USA wake
and wake
Sports so I plan to talk for about three
minutes I did submit
testimony I primarily represent the
sport or activity on the
water so we're a member proud member of
the US Olympic and Par Olympic
Committee that Association represents
the interest of athletes and water sport
clubs in the state of New Hampshire
promoting tow sports that
includes wake sports with local Regional
National and international on the Water
Events as toad waterports nears its3
aniversary celebration of water skiing
we're back in 1922 we had 18-year-old
Ralph Samson who pondered the idea you
know we all love snow skiing he said if
you can ski on snow then you can ski on
water we're allware the sports
evolving we too share the same position
for our Great Outdoors in New Hampshire
transition transitioning from winter to
summer Sports attracting National and
international members to our sanctioned
practices and tournaments every
year our association is opposed to House
Bill
229 as representative gunky indicated I
was also a member of House Bill 137 on a
part of that
commission and the commission did not in
our opinion recommend defining wake
boats I actually own a a ski Nati uh
that that is a ski boat that's what it's
defined as but it does have ballast bags
in the back for trick skiing one of our
competitions that we actually hold up in
wolfboro in Back Bay and so that's very
important to us we feel that that
particular definition uh unfortunately
does not really Define our sport or
activity and that it it really has
impending consequences that surround
that as as many of you know in in snow
skiing uh there is adaptive Sports we
also have adaptive Sports in water
skiing the Northeast passage of Durham
in collaboration with
UNH uh is very active in that and that's
something that those that those ballast
bags are required to help folks uh have
a good experience behind the boat uh it
gives them
ability uh to you know gain air just
like you would in say snowboarding or
other aerial Sports and so in our
opinion that's something that uh you we
really feel uh is is pretty important uh
one thing just to bring up that was part
of the commission study uh was the
impact Beyond of what was considered
with uh wake booat waves was actually
the natural occurrence of the natural
freeze and thaw that we experience every
year year uh you know wind waves
flooding from rains Dam regulation and
most of those concerns of of shorel
owners are those that have modified that
property front you know they've made
they've turned into grass they've
they've cut down the blueberry bushes so
uh again thank you for your time uh we
229 thank you any questions from members
of the
committee
I see no questions seeing none thank you
very much Mr
bner thank you next I have uh honorable
Pam price uh another member of the
weight commission and speaking in
minutes price representative price yes
hello Mr chairman can you hear me uh yes
we can let me just because the same
thing name Town what do you represent
and time you wish to speak and on video
do have speak
slowly thank you Mr chairman um my name
is uh Pamela price I'm a former
four-term state representative I'm a
member of House Bill 137 commissioned to
study wake boats I'm a resident of snipe
and an owner of a tobo and I will speak
for less than five minutes I'm going to
try to speak slowly um I'm here to
testify in opposition to House Bill
229 the bill before you today seeks to
Define wake boats it simply defines one
type of boat without specifying what is
to be done with the
definition when I was in the legislature
we identified problems determined
Solutions and defined who who the
solution or change in law pertain to
this bill sets the definition without
identifying a problem or solution a
definition can only do one thing and
that is to lead to further restriction
and regulation down the
road that this is not a recommendation
of the commission the commission heard
from a number of organizations on the
subject AIS spread is down because of
vigilance on all boats the manufacturers
are adding new technology the water
sport industry Association is leading a
Boer education and wake responsibly
campaign recommending in part boers stay
200 foot from Shore while wake surfing
we learned from a retired MIT engineer
who conducted a
scientific wave action study that wake
surf waves are the largest just behind
the boat
and they subside quickly as they get
closer to shore the larger waves lose
their energy quicker than the smaller
waves and the study showed that the wave
from a wake surfing boat was no
different than a wave from a 10 m hour
wind the busiest days on the lake are
the weekends and in the summer and
approximate 20 days which has which has
much less impact on the shore than a
year round wind we received many letters
to the commission the majority from
families who enjoy water sports and
don't want to see them limited or banned
by restricting type of boats there is a
segment of the population that dislike
the boats and they blame them for all
the ills on their Lake we did not see
evidence to support
this the commission was able to agree on
a number of recommendations and that was
the subject of house
bill5 five that you previously heard
personally our family has participated
in a range of water sports for over 30
years we live on the water in the summer
we love our towboat because we can do
everything behind it ski wakeboard surf
kneeboard and tube and now we're sharing
our love for the water with our two
grandkids ages 5 and three the
confidence and excitement our grandson
shows when kneeboarding tubing and yes
learning to wake serf is priceless Lake
sunpi was particularly busy this past
summer as many families spent time
together outside during the covid
pandemic the state of New Hampshire
holds in trust all public waters for the
use and the benefit of the people of the
state it's the governing principle to
balance the competing uses of the public
and the shorefront owners the state
safeguards this by avoiding peace meal
on water regulation one of the key
Provisions is the reasonable use of the
Water Resources it's our responsibility
to share the water responsibly and not
allow one interest group to determine
the fate of another the commission had
strong recommendations to improve voter
Behavior through education there are
clearly voters who create problems that
need to be addressed but house bill 229
is not the answer House Bill 229 takes a
drastic step towards limiting the rights
of people who have purchased a
commercially available boat for the
enjoyment of their family there was no
compelling evidence presented to subject
law-abiding voters to Future bans and
restrictions and without such evidence
the voting Community has the right to
the reasonable use of New Hampshire's
public waterways I ask that you find
this bill inexpedient to legislate and I
will submit my testimony uh to you all
after thank you very much Mr chairman
and members of the
committee thank you representative is
there any questions by the members of
the committee sir I see no questions
seeing none thank you very
much
representative representative
R hello again uh colleagues on the
resources committee um for the record my
name is Rosemarie rang I'm a state
representative from marac which is
Hillsboro 21 um I'm actually speaking to
you today as a summer resident of molten
Boro New Hampshire my husband and I have
a summer home on Lake kisaka which is a
371 acre Lake um right on the edge of
molteno uh kind of straddling Center
Harbor um it's a small Lake but it's
large enough for um motorboats skiing um
sailing swimming everything everything
like that um one of our residents has
purchased a wake boat and has had it on
uh on the lake for last summer and I can
tell you I I know we've heard a lot
about people saying oh these boats
aren't really different I invite each of
you to come up to my place in the summer
and you will see quite clearly the
difference between a wake booat and a
regular motorboat um it will swamp the
shoreline um and I'm sure that it does
it does contribute to
erosion um I also think that um this
past summer we had a lake wide cyano
bacteria Bloom it made our lake look
like PE soup and um there and like Mr
oon ran said from the new New Hampshire
Lakes is that our Lake doesn't isn't
necessarily deep like other Lakes um we
have certain spots that are deep but
wake boats definitely turn up churn up
the sediment and and increase the
phosphorous load of the water um
someone's pet dog nearly died children
got sick um parent a swimmer that swims
the lake every day got very sick um so
wake boats you know they they can
contribute to uh conditions which can
can lead to cyano bacteria blooms and
and actually and actually actually have
actually have a
very um no one could be in our Lake for
a month because of that cyano bacteria
Bloom and then we had localized blooms
followed for several weeks so I'm not
against wake boats um my husband and I
we had a motorboat we now have gotten
old enough for a pontoon boat so we just
kind of you know do our little cruise
around the lake but um wake boats are
different and we need to Define them um
just as this committee redefined or
defined a personal watercraft a couple
years ago um we need to have these
definitions in place yes there may come
a time when on certain lakes that don't
have the depths of others that wake
boats might have to be restricted um to
have a a greater distance from Shore um
some shallow Lakes they may not be able
to to to be maneuvered because of the
damage they can cause so I strongly
support this bill and I hope you uh vote
ought to pass thank
you any questions by members of the
question representative post
representative post for a question thank
you Mr chair and um thank you uh
representative r i my question is on
your leg around your Lake do most of the
homes have uh grass around it on their
property
uh there there's some that have grass
but we are a a lake that is striving to
be a lak smart Community it's a
designation by the New Hampshire Lakes
um we have mainly around there's uh
trees uh we try to keep a natural uh uh
buffer
between land and in the lake but there
are a few homes that do have more of a
grassy front I know in our property we
actually have a natural Beach for it
might be I don't know maybe 20 or 30
feet
long it's a mix if I had to
say m Mr chairman may I do a followup to
that we have a time go right ahead okay
yes um so in in reading about cob
bacterial blooms it's usually from
excess nutrients coming in from uh
people fertilizing and things like that
it's also caused in times of heat so how
how do you attribute um the cob bacteria
in lakes that don't have these to the
situation you had this
year well um I've kind of actually
become uh more or less a semi-expert on
cyano bacteria Blooms from our
experience
we've always had I mean the only thing
that's changed on our lake has been the
Wake booat um we also have uh you know
some sometimes animal droppings can
increase the phosphorus load but the
cyano bacteria Bloom is generated or
primarily caused from an increase in
phosphorus and phosphorus can come from
disruption of sediment uh yes we do have
other areas that may be sources of a of
a cyano bacteria Bloom but what we
experienced last summer was was Lake
wide the whole lake was like PE soup it
wasn't as though you look on a Shore and
you see a scum from a cyanobacteria
bloom there are different types the type
we experien was from Lake wide
phosphorus
loading I don't know if that answers
your qu I mean there are many different
sources of cyanobacteria blooms but
almost all of them are caused from
increase in phosphorus loading from
sediment
disruption thank
you there's no more seeing no more
questions thank you very much represent
representative thank you chairman
renzullo next to representative norren
silver he's up representative
silver I I'm here thank you and I I know
the rules uh I this is Norman silver I
live in Guilford I'm belnap District 2
representing the towns of Guilford and
Meredith both on Lake Winn pasak uh I
have been asked by constituents to
vigorously oppose H Bill 229 House Bill
229 in in listening to the uh discussion
of the committee on the prior Bill
115 uh I noticed a lot of emphasis on
the manner of propulsion of the boats
and that we were talking in terms that
wake boats did not have or should not
have an outboard engine at the back or a
a a rear drive to protect the person who
was being tow there's no mention of the
manner of propulsion in this definition
this could apply the definition could
certainly apply to a stern drive or an
outboard engine propelled boat as
written it doesn't focus on the
propulsion method which is contrary to
the intent of the safety Provisions in
115 the the constituents that asked me
to oppose this were first of all one in
the Marine industry who sells the boats
and the other was a physician who lives
on the lake and who likes to to use uh
the toast Sports likes to engage in the
tow Sports including wake
surfing our view is my view their view
is that the definition is the beginning
of a slippery slope the first step is
you define something next you regulate
it then you restrict it and ultimately
you ban it and that's the concern here
with putting this definition the way it
is now is it's going to lead to a
ultimately regulation restrictions and
banning of uh surfing so we urge that
the committee vote itl thank you
thank you very
much I'm no longer going to take
questions from the members of the
committee
uh next I have representative
mories
hello yeah uh you know if you heard the
ground rules yes I have this is
representative Mike boards I represent
lonia um belnap District 3 um I'm also
on Lake Winn pasak I'm actually out on
the low on uh out on the lake every day
during the summer um I'll be honest with
you there is absolutely no difference
between a 56 foot boat that travels
along the lake and what you guys want to
declare as a wake boat um I think by
defining this all you're doing is
setting up future regulations against a
good sport and a good uh help to our
economy up here and I really think you
legislate that that your
testimony that would be it for now I
just wanted to get my point across that
a lot of constituents um are very
unhappy about this definition and um
want to be brief with you guys I thank
much Captain
D
available yes Mr chair I'm available
thank you there's your the again the
only person representing state
government uh so
[Music]
in can you give us some testimony give
us your
perspective thank you Mr chair and
honorable members of the resources
committee my name is Tim Dunley and I am
the captain of the State Police Marine
Patrol unit uh the department of safety
uh is taking a neutral position on this
bill this is not uncommon for our agency
to take this approach when there are uh
potential impacts for various users of
our public Waters uh it is the position
of the department to allow the public
process uh whether it be through the
hearings process or the legislative
process to implement restrictions Andor
in this case definitions uh as they
uh would would deem appropriate I'm
happy to answer any uh background
questions that any of you may have but
uh the position of the department is to
remain neutral in this
case I will open
committee I see no questions no
questions thank you very
much Michelle Davis with
newes
Lakes hi Mr chair and members of the
committee can you hear me uh yes uh can
you try we're uh running out around the
second half of this so
whole I will keep this very brief um as
Tom covered a lot of what I was planning
to talk about um I am Michelle Davis I'm
the advocacy program coordinator at New
Hampshire lakes and I really just wanted
to make a few points that New Hampshire
Lakes is not now trying to ban ballast
boats or that activities of wake
boarding and wake
surfing uh we're acting in response to
increasing concerns from both members
and non-members alike who are concerned
about their property damage and
increasing inability to use their
favorite Lake safely for other uses uh
we believe that any onw waterer activity
that negatively impacts the health of
our Lakes as well as negatively impacts
other boers
swimmers Shoreline structures Mor boats
Etc needs to be better managed than it
is now uh our lakes are in the public
trust and for the use and enjoyment of
everyone ballast boats are I will remind
you prohibitively expensive and choosing
not to manage or mitigate their impacts
is choosing the enjoyment of a few over
the protection of the
many and the Boating industry would have
you believe that the waves created by
ballast boats are no different than
wakes created by any other boat
while simultaneously advertising huge
wakes to prospective buyers right now
Malibu is advertising an engine called
the Malibu Monsoon for an example so
wake boats are fundamentally designed to
create enhanced wakes and therefore have
a greater impact on our Lakes thank
much
yeah back to the top of the list where
we go to Daniel
frin of the public opposed to the bill
on five minutes uh
no Mr
Fred I have a Dan but no last name sir
Dan
frin
what's
FR all right let's go to the next
one
Julia julus
s
lightness I do not see her
okay going moving right
chase she ready car chase are you
there all right you said you're asking
for five minutes I cannot give you five
minutes can you do it in two I can do it
as quickly as possible I can def itely
do it in two or three minutes for
sure after three minutes we we will be
turning we will be flipping the switch
you're up okay fair enough my name is
Cara Chase I'm a resident of Belmont New
Hampshire and I'm here to speak to you
in opposition of Bill HB 229 defining
wake boats good afternoon Mr chairman
and members of the committee um I am a
resident of New Hampshire and I'm a
mother of two young children Kendall age
12 and bod age 9 I'm the wife to a
professional Free Ride mountain biker
and the managing partner of the Legacy
home group at Keller Williams lakes and
mountains realy I was born and raised in
New Hampshire and I'm the fourth
generation of an 86-year-old lak wabaki
business the Nazar Resort located in
pagus I grateful for the opportunity to
speak to you today my husband and I
moved away from New Hampshire in 2002 to
relocate to New Jersey to explore the
world outside of our tiny state in which
we were bornn and raised in 2016 we made
the conscious choice to move our family
back to New Hampshire to create the same
opportunity for our children to be
raised in the beautiful lakes and
mountains as we were raised we both grew
up on lake wiip pasak and felt drawn
back home two years ago we purchas
purchased our first wake boat from
Silver Sands Marina we chose the boat we
did because as an active family we knew
we needed a boat that would keep us
active and engaged in a healthy
lifestyle the boat we purchased offered
us that exact opportunity come 2020 we
decided it was time to upgrade and we
traded in our first boat and purchased
another wake boat from Silver Sands yes
we bought two boats in two years and
this shows our passion for the lifestyle
that we as a family have become
accustomed to during this time we made
friends with some amazing families that
share the same passion for wake surfing
that we do we watched our young kids
collectively progress gain confidence
where otherwise they may not have and
quick become a community of families who
would join together for the love of the
lake and water sports we have created a
tradition in our family that we ride
mountain bikes in the morning and then
hang up the bikes and hedge the marina
in the afternoon to Surf with family and
friends this is something we all look
forward to and it keeps our kids active
with us off screens and engaged in
something that brings them Joy
confidence and friendship beyond my
passion for my family's love of our wake
booat we we I'd like to speak speak
briefly from the business perspective
being the fourth generation of the Nazar
Resort and a successful real estate
agent I can tell you I know how
restrictions made on the Lakes will
impact our businesses in tourism I
recently showed a couple from New Jersey
a smaller home a a lake a home on a
smaller Lake in our area they love the
lake they love the house but did not
purchase because they would not be able
to have their personal watercraft on
this Lake that seller's buyer pool was
directly affected by that by the fact
that personal watercraft were not
allowed on this Lake the naasa is a
prominent business on Lake wiip pasak
for over 86 years this business relies
on our boating community servicing the
local tourism industry with over 85
rooms and 50 dock slips and two
restaurants my family's businesses rely
directly on these tourism dollars and as
we add more and more restrictions we
will see these tourists second
homeowners choose different areas to
recreate causing these family run
regr audio settings going here
guys can you hear me now okay my name is
Stephen McGrath I live in sunap New
Hampshire I am speaking as an individual
Boer two and three minutes I understand
that my background is I own an OP the
dinner boats on Lake Sun I've been a
lifelong boater here and I'm an
passionate water skier and also an owner
of an 18t Century Resorter I'm speaking
to support this bill on safety concerns
when we water ski in the morning despite
the fact that the Wake surge boats are
away from us the only safe way we can
accomplish that wake is to take our
water ski boat from 32 miles hour to
zero it's a 21 foot Mumba we cannot
safely go over those wakes even when the
wake surf boat is a couple three 400
yards away from us also when I'm driving
my Century resor on a windy day I need
to be conscious of those waves as well
because when they hit my bow Century
Resort 1986 when I hit my bow it slows
my boat down dramatically a knot or two
or three causing my prop to cavitate
causing my motor to overr I wasn't too
happy this summer when we did Miss awake
on a windy day and my butt came off the
boat cushion 10 inches that's a lot
that's unsafe now I'd like to see this
bill passed so that a class of boats
wake surge boats just as with jet skis
and I'm familiar with that legislation
can be enacted so that
responsible let's call them responsible
opportunities to educate voters can be
formulated thank you very
Mr
d
dman d g n d g
n not see that not see that I don't
Molly
either
on
[Music]
it's Gerald are you
got Scott Boehner but no Scott
Fitzgerald yeah okay Mr
Lu hi can you hear me uh yes uh you
looking for three minutes keep it under
three minutes if I I will definitely
keep it under three minutes my name is
Al I live on Lake sopy I've booted on
Lake sopy since
1985 um and I'm speaking against uh the
bill um um I'm not going to repeat the
comments uh Pam price uh really
addressed most of what I was going to
say I think she said it very well um I I
just want to add this one of the
representatives commented on uh whether
Pete mcallum would support or his
Association would support more money for
enforcement on the lake I actually think
that that's a problem that's much more
important than the problem being
addressed uh today by this definition of
a wake surfing boat uh uh on Lake sunap
we can sometimes go weeks without seeing
um a marine safety officer um I suspect
on some of the smaller Lakes you never
see a marine safety officer and I think
we should spend our time focusing on
raising revenue for more boating safety
officers uh I I've never seen an issue
with a safety uh from a wake surfing
boat they move
slowly um I've seen a lot of issues with
boats going too fast regardless of the
weight they're putting out whether it's
a ski booat going too quickly and Too
Close um and so I think this committee
would would be well served to spend its
time figuring out ways to increase uh
enforcement of the existing rules with
Nickerson good evening chairman and
representatives my name is Guy Nickerson
representing my family resident of
Guilford New Hampshire on Lake wabaki
one minute presentation my family and I
would like to express our opposition to
House Bill 229 having been a resident
New Hampshire resident for 40 years
we've spent 30 years sailing and boating
including towboat using towboats on New
Hampshire waters for the last five years
I've been the treasur of the lake wiip
pasak Sailing Association where we
pledge to Foster safety self-c conidence
teamwork honesty positive sporting
values and appreciation for our
environment I've been a member of New
Hampshire Lakes my family and I promote
healthy water quality and Safe Water
ways in the state of New Hampshire and
our opposed to House Bill
229 thank you for your time and
muchan
Hanley all right can you hear me uh yes
you represent the Lake wnab basaki
Association yes I do and I'll I'll take
probably two minutes at the most okay we
appreciate that thank you the floor is
yours okay uh um my name is Diane Hanley
I'm from Guilford New Hampshire and I am
representing Lake wiip Baki Association
today um so thank you for taking my
testimony um we've been lwa has been
advocating for the big lake for over 40
years um our primary focus is on
protecting the water quality of the lake
we support the wide variety of uses by
motor boers and everybody else unlik
wiip as long as as those uses are
not disproportionately harmful to water
quality um due to the newness of
wakeboarding there's not a large body of
data on their impact um but we have
received dozens of reports from our
members and others that they are
witnessing seemingly more and
significant erosion to the Shoreline and
churning of the lake bed in relation to
the use of wake
boats um those things it's already been
covered uh once you start moving
sediment around in the water column
you're going to get all kinds of
problems like growing mil foil and algae
and plant growth and stuff
um so I would just like to point out
that the increase in popularity of the
Wake boats which is understandable and
the increase in residents directly
observing changes to their water quality
is likely to continue even if you do not
act this year setting up all kinds of
conflicts between the lake
users um so we think that all Lake using
constituents voters kayakers swimmers
Etc deserve a way to define the issues
so that their needs can be addressed
whatever way we move forward on that um
so lakip Association urges you to
support HB 229 in this session thank
you thank you very
much
Jeff Mark Jeff the chair would recognize
Mark
Jeff
Jeff no Bart
mute
Mr
mlay are you still on
mute only
once going twice on to the next one
stepen
Raymond Mr Raymond are you
there's up Sir Mr Raymond ah there you
are
okay have you been listening you been
saying thing is name
town be
represents how time and speak slowly
video If You Can we'll
do Steve Raymond from Manchester New
Hampshire um I plan to speak for two
minutes uh I'm in opposition of House
Bill
229 uh I'm a New Hampshire native since
I was eight I spent my Summers growing
up on Lake winnisquam my wife daughter
and I are also fortunate enough to now
have our own property on the lake and
spend countless hours on it with family
and friends water sports and
specifically wake Sports have shaped me
into the person I am today my love of
wakeboarding has allowed me to travel
the country competing through my younger
years is how I actually met my wife has
allowed me to develop friendships with
individuals and families that continue
to be a large part of my family's life
and is the reason I chose the
educational and career path I am still
on today I'm an environmental engineer
and I specialize in remedial
construction management I have spent
most of my 22-year career dedicated to
improving the environment we live in
with that said I would not
wholeheartedly support a sport that
damaged the natural resources we are all
so lucky to have in New Hampshire and
that I have worked every day to protect
and restore I am disappointed that this
effort to Define and later potentially
ban or restrict wake boats is being led
by a loud minority that doesn't like
wake boats mainly due to their own
personal reasons I even more
disappointed than an organization such
as New Hampshire Lakes is diverting from
their important mission to keep New
Hampshire Lakes clean and healthy in its
willingness to employ its resources and
falsely utilize the environment as its
rally and cry to regulate wake boats
issues they blame on Wake boats such as
erosion are impacted far greater by wind
ice fluctuating water levels and
improper Shoreline development concerns
such as invasive species apply to all
boats
however why aren't they as concerned
about live wells and bass boats
regardless of personal agendas New
Hampshire is a state where safe and
responsible use of our resources is part
of what makes New Hampshire and its
recreational economy so great rules and
regulations are already in place to
allow safe and responsible use of our
Water Resources no matter what Pastime
you might enjoy in closing more focus
should be spent on education and
enforcement through proper funding of
such State organizations as New
Hampshire Marine Patrol and less focus
on the agenda of a special interest
minority thank you very much for your
time thank you thank you Mr
Raymond our next first our next speaker
Shannon
Reed shanon Reed good afternoon can you
can you hear me uh yes uh say two
minutes I will certainly yes thank you
my name is Shannon Reed I am a full-time
resident of epom New Hampshire and I
live on Northwood lake with my husband
and kids I'm speaking in opposition to
hospital
229 I sent a letter to the committee
earlier this week so you have that and I
will not repeat what I said here I'll
just make three quick points and refer
you to my letter for the rest first and
most important I believe this bill
scapegoats one type of boat instead of
setting and enforcing rules for all
boter to follow all boers can cause an
impact on New Hampshire's Lakes whether
it's operators of small fishing boats or
kayaks that can spread aquatic weeds by
moving from one Lake to another or very
large boats that make a big wake no
matter what they do any kind of boat
that comes too close to Shore or to
other people or any boater creating
unsafe conditions by not absorbing the
rules about sharing our
waterways second wake surfing can be
done on a variety of different types of
boats people are Innovative it's unclear
if this bill is even working
the bill defines wake surfing which can
be accomplished in a variety of ways
third the commission last year which
studied this issue at length after
hearing extensive and well-informed
testimony reviewing research and
thoughtfully considering this issue from
many perspectives the commission
expressly declined to recommend the
measures in hille 229 but unanimously
recommended
education on a personal note I can't say
enough about how these multi-purpose
bootes have brought
me really cherished family time I my
husband and I have two
teenagers as I have gotten older there
are a lot of things I can no longer do
that I used to love like water skiing
surfing is pretty gentle actually and
something I can still do at the same
time my teenagers love it and this has
been almost the one thing that can
always peel them away from their screens
make them just happy and Outdoors and
engaged something we all do and love to
do together it gave my daughter
confidence it helped my son learn
responsibil ability for taking care of
something it's created the kind of
family memories that will last a
lifetime I hope you will not take steps
that will eventually make it just a
memory but will allow other families to
experience what we have voting activity
done responsibly can and should be
preserved and I hope you will not single
out one type of vote against evidence
thank you very much for your
time thank
you
there he's on the phone and on mute so
second star six press star six to unmute
mute Chris
Hut star six to
unmute
Chris
you only once the
tce
hins Chris
hins on to the next
yio is not
Golder Evan Goldman I don't have I do
not have a Goldman on the
phone there is no Evan
Goldman Ray
Hendrickson so he has up hand up on day
he's had his hand up all day he's ready
uh yes my name is Ray Hendrickson from
Hein I'd like two minutes can you hear
me yes you're on uh I am a thank you I
am a shorefront owner on newfound Lake
and owner of what is considered a wake
booat since 1990 I a pioneer of wake
boats I purchased three wake B boats
over the last 30 years from Silver Sands
I'm sure they're happy with my business
and Storage
and repair uh as well that's helped
their their business thank you for
allowing me to speak as a lifelong New
Hampshire boating Enthusiast I want to
indicate my opposition to
h229 I do own a wake booat along with a
pontoon boat and two jet skis my family
uses each of them responsibly and safely
the wake booat is the one we use for
teaching the grandkids to water ski and
wakeboard and doing so has had them fall
in love with new new cure Lakes like I
did in my early
20s I believe that creating a separate
category for Wake boats is completely
misguided it is not right to Target wake
boats as many non wake boats create
similar or even significantly larger
wakes than wake boats boats such as bow
Riders loaded with people or any large
heavy boat creates larger wakes than
wake boats to State Wake boats create
the largest wakes possible is misleading
as many non- wake boats create
significantly larger wakes I know there
are times that wake booat operators play
loud music but the same can be said for
pontoon boat operators
too it's just not right for Wake boats
to be classified differently when
clearly this is a first step in
targeting them for increased regul
regulation for which there is no basis
I've been a proud New Hampshire
Lakefront landowner and boat owner since
1990 and I love New Hampshire's motto of
Live Free or Die please do everything
you can to avoid unnecessary and
misplaced first step of targeting reg or
targeted regulation of wake boats in our
free
much Robin
Shield she's on mute okay all right
thank you okay I'm Robin shield and I'm
from Center Harbor and during the summer
I live uh Lakeside in holderness and I'm
here representing myself and my family
and I'll speak less than two
minutes okay as a lifelong motorboating
Enthusiast I support this wake booat
defining bill I live on the shore of a
particularly popular Cove for water
skiing tubing and toe Sports my Cove has
a permitted water ski course even I have
seen firsthand in practice that wake
boats are fundamentally different from
other motorboats despite contrary
descriptions today I am not anti- motor
boating and the family FR fun it brings
to our economy my father owns a marina
on little Squam so I'm definitely not
any motorboating I'd like to tell you
what I personally have seen that
describes how wake booat waves are
different at the shore even when
generated from much more more distant
than 200 yards from Shore and I wouldn't
be here today if Wake boats are just
like other
boats now though with wake boats I have
a situation in which the waves are much
larger than even a natural storm Gale
could blow up on the particular
Shoreline that my property is on this is
not the case with other style motorboats
Shores cannot withstand the force of
that unnaturally High wake it is
entirely different from all the other
motorboat wake which is considerable in
the Cove that I'm in Wake boats are
different my hundred-year-old ston wall
at the shore had withstood all previous
boat activity until now due to the
intense sloshing wave action at the
shoreline wake booat wake is different
so now my boat and dock is sloshed
around much more causing me to need to
purchase a boat lift to get my boat out
of the water spending money to save both
my Dock and boat from the tugging and
banging from the confused water sloshing
at the Shore wake booat wake is
different the shoreline sediments are
being disrupted and washed into the lake
at the shoreline the natural shrub
Shoreline The Roots the little plant
life and the sediments are sosed
inundated exposed and washed into the
lake now many of the reasons that the
dees protects the shorelines I'm seeing
are being harmed by these unnaturally
large wakes much bigger than anything
that is blown up by winds in my area of
the lake wake boats are different than
all other motorboats they're causing New
Economic costs to me and environmental
damage to the plants and animals in the
shallows at the edge of the lake and
damage to the Natural community on the
shoreline their extra- llarge wake does
make them different category of boat and
I think they need defining thank
grimas
yeah
me floor is yours hi for the record my
name is Jody gmis I represent the water
sports industry Association I sent to
the committee last night a letter from
the industry um and want to make sure
that you had seen that if not I can make
sure send it again couple of points I
will make and then be brief because
there are others that want to
testify first there was a discussion
about a Nas BL definition being adopted
um at the national level for a
definition of wake boo that definition
has not been actually adopted it's
actually just being discussed um so we
ask that you you know consider that that
there is no national definition of wakeo
at this time while there are discussions
um we we would oppose those discussions
um and we certainly see that there's
what the impact of a definition will do
in New Hampshire is our
concern second in the email that I sent
there's also a video of the study on
wave action that was brought before the
house bill 137 commission it's a
two-minute video I can resend it if
anybody would like to see but I think it
shows you gives you a good sense of what
the waves look like as they come to
shore um again it's in the email that I
sent and I can certainly follow up again
um and then third just another point on
the Wake responsibly campaign it's an
educational campaign supported by just
not only the national associations but
also the local New Hampshire dealers and
voters um that education campaign kicked
off uh quite honestly in the middle of
the summer after house schille 137 um
came up with its recommendations that
campaign is going to go into full effect
and we believe that campaign with again
asking wake Surfers to do so 200 feet
away from Shore as well as the other
best practices will go a long way to
making sure that everybody is using this
the waterways responsibly I am happy to
answer any questions I can um if there
are questions that you need further
followup I'm happy to get those answers
for you but I appreciate your time and
efforts thank
you thank you very much next person is
Carl
leing uh asking for 15 minutes uh you're
going to get
two can you hear me hear me or see us
right you're
on okay my name is Carl lining I'm from
do Hampshire I'm here representing
myself um uh Amy my family uh Amy and
Alexia we live on the Bellamy River in
the Great Bay Area um so we're on the
water all the time we have this we have
uh we do care about our um our property
as well but we also have a wakeboard um
boat and we've been both voting for many
years myself uh starting 30 years ago
and wake surfing for 20 years um I'm not
going to repeat the things that have
already been discussed but I want to
point out some things that haven't been
discussed and focused on the definition
itself um first of all I'm opposed to
House Bill
229 defining a wake booat to limit wakes
is like trying to define a sports car to
limit fast cars all cars go fast all
boats create can create a big weight you
just put enough people on it that's how
surfing got started you put a bunch of
friends on the boat you created a big
wake and you can go wake surfing um this
definition instead of creating a
definition to go after the Wake boats
you enforce the laws like we enforce
speeding
laws where do you draw the line the
current definition of wake booat doesn't
even capture all current wake boats one
feature that hasn't been discussed that
one manufacturer makes is a plane it's
like a wing underneath the boat that
pulls the bow down into the water the
definition does not capture
that there's other ways that you can uh
weigh the boat down that's what makes
the Wake the definition therefore is
unfair improper and arbitrary it targets
only certain manufacturers of boats
owners and manufacturers will find a way
around the definition the result is that
it will not solve the problem the
solution educate instead of eradicate
people create the big disturbing wakes
not the Wake boats it's a few bad apples
spoiling the bunch two recent students
attending boating certificate course
said that they weren't taught that they
own their own weake we need to educate
we also need to educate Shoreline
Property Owners to start parking their
boats perpendicular to shore with the
bow facing deep water use of moing whips
to also prevent boating damage or any of
their concerns also educate them on
vegetation and things that they can
plant to prevent erosion the the the
definition is is also I got three
important points that haven't been
discussed that I would like to discuss
if you would please the definition is
putting undue burden on Marine Patrol if
this is ever turned into a law Marine
Patrol would have to be looking for
ballast tanks bags compartments
containers Plumbing and doing a full
search of a boat this is undue burden on
Marine Patrol and then what is quote
unquote A system that is too vague for a
definition to be put into this
definition even the commission is split
on what the definition of wakeboard boat
would be we can't it's just way too
vague to have a proper definition then
detain uh
ashor are you there yep can you hear me
now all right uh you've asked for uh 10
minutes oh I don't need 10 minutes I
didn't know how to estimate it honestly
governor minutes I appreciate it sure
sure um good afternoon honorable members
of the resource Recreation and
development committee thank you for
giving me an opportunity to talk today I
strongly oppose the house bill 229 I
have grave concerns that this bill wants
to identify one type of boat to single
it out and ultimately ban it or restrict
its use on specific lakes and waterways
in our
state first I want you to know I'm a
resident of Guilford New Hampshire and
I've lived in the state for 11 years and
live on the water in Saunders Bay in
Guilford I have 100 feet of Shoreline
with a perched beach that is supported
with a stone wall a permanent wooden
dock a moing and stone
Shoreline we have a Mastercraft wake
booat this is actually the second that
we've had for over 10 years two of them
purchased from Silver Sands and Guilford
this is a wonderful place to live and
raise two daughters I also want to
mention with our wake booat that we wake
board water ski and two behind our boat
and it doesn't put off much of a wake at
all nothing more than a typical water
sports
boat to Define our boat would
potentially limit all water sports we do
with our boat not just wake
surfing my understanding is individuals
have concerns that wake boats cause
erosion of the shoreline have to say I
believe the waves caused by the large
Carver boats and Yachts over 40 feet
even the Mount Washington and the
mailboat with a wide beam put off much
larger wakes than wake
boats I'm just trying to make this
smaller for you here um the waves that
they put off when they leave the leave
the bay we have the marina right to the
right of our property it goes to the far
reaches of the shoreline of our Bay if a
wake surf boat is offshore by at least
150 to 200 feet and away from other
boers sub borders Kay actors by at least
100 feet there shouldn't be any issues
we surf on a daily basis in our Bay and
have never had an issue with erosion of
our walk rock wall our property are any
damage to our boats on our permanent
dock or the boat that's on our moing in
front of our house neither have any of
our neighbors when we surf it's at a
very low rate of speed only nine to 10
miles an hour when our ball
yes your two minutes are up okay can I
just let me just finish I'm I'm making
it smaller just wrap it up yep if we
went any faster we would lose our wave
and we do not surf in Shallow Waters so
we are not causing any sediment issues
or stirring up the bottom a nor Easter
storm causes far more erasion erosion
than a surfing session behind a wake
booat and a typical surf session is not
more than an hour just so that you know
it's a very athletic Sport and we
wouldn't have that opportunity and nor
would it cause any erosion I just want
to let you know that I ask that you do
not support any legislation to Define
wake surf boats on winaki these boats
are used for family cruises across the
lake Family Ice Cream run on the lake a
date night for dinner they're not just
for surfing I thank you to take the time
to hear my thoughts and observations and
hope it provides you with a positive
Insight from someone that's owned a wake
boat for over 10 years and enjoyed it
with my husband and two daughters thank
you thank you very much uh
Deborah
p
deah okay can you hear me uh yes all
right um I'll be very quick I have
submitted my test on Deborah deyer I
live in conquered I am um here to
support HB
229 um I will not reading what I wrote
which was short but what I do want to uh
talk about briefly and I'll be very
quick is I support 29 229 I am not
interested in Banning anything I'm a
resident of Squam Lake um I want to be
able to enjoy my time on Squam as much
as those in a boat that creates these
large wakes is enjoying their time um th
people are debating whether the large
wakes cause a problem they do I can no
longer sit in my Dock and read a book on
a towel I can wave at motor at the the
motorboats going by with skiers but when
a ballast boat goes by I if I don't get
up and get off the dock I am drenched my
book is drenched the towel is drenched
my grandchildren when they swim in their
little floaties on the side of the dock
uh this summer in in fact we were in the
Water swimming with them a ballast boat
or a wake boat went by and the boat's
wave actually knocked the kids under the
water even we were there so it was fine
I mean it was safe we were there but
that is it incredible amount of water it
has diminished our ability to enjoy our
spot on the lake I don't want to ban
anything but there's a place where all
of these things can be done
appropriately but you can't even have a
conversation about it until you
understand the difference that these
boats are the different kind of boat
they are from what has traditionally
been on the lake and we've been on the
lake 35 years this is a very different
phenomenon and it does impact everyone's
equal ability to enjoy enjoy the lake
thank you thank you very
much
Stevens
students are you there I'm here and how
much can you do this under two
minutes
yep the floor is yours well thanks for
having me today Brie Stevens I am the
proprietor of a real estate company in
The Lakes region of New Hampshire I
reside in molbo and dock my Mastercraft
towboat on lake wabaki in Santa Harbor
Bay I'm an elected member of the town of
molon Barrow's planning board a member
of the development committee for the
Lake wabaki Association as well as a
volunteer for the lon preservation
committee I've always been privileged to
enjoy all the opportunities that growing
with the lake has to offer whether it's
been a canoe driving a jet ski families
boat what have you I try to enjoy being
on the lake almost every day in the
summer months I enjoy our tobo for
personal and work related purposes
whether it be for cruising the lake
taking clients to showings or teaching
friends families and clients how to surf
I host Surf and cruise nights with
clients and members of the community
weekly during these summer months you
can often find my husband or myself
teaching new Surfers of all ages from 7
to 70 years old the thrill of Surfing
tubing or water skiing on the lake many
different types of boats participate in
this same recreational sport as towboats
a large difference being that inboard
motor we've been discussing this allows
for the water sport known as wake
surfing to take place since the
propeller is safe distance underneath
wake surfing takes place at an average
speed of 10 miles an hour on the wakes
wave a three 10 3 to 10 ft from the back
of the boat platform there are less boat
passes in water than surfing with
surfing than any other water sport while
wig surfing on a towboat only one side
of the boat has a wake wave where the
other is minimal resulting with half the
impact of any other type of boat that
does not have the control of the size of
their wave nor on just using one side
for waves in the real estate world it is
my experience that many buyers are
looking to move here to enjoy all the
Lakes have to offer including water
sports using all kinds of boats they
want the recreation Lake Life water
sports particularly wake surfing and if
they were to be affected I know buyers
would begin looking elsewhere when it
comes okay your time is
up thank you very
toay Cody
gray hello good evening thank you you
have two
minutes thank you um uh I am uh on this
meeting to oppose uh House Bill 229 uh
my position though is uh I live in
Molton Boro uh I represent good Hue Boat
Company uh we have three locations
wolfboro uh Meredith and uh Lake sopy
and uh along with our 50 uh plus uh
employees we we oppos this uh proposed
legislation I I am however sympathetic
to uh the individual that uh that that
are proposing uh the legislation I
understand that um you know large waves
and repetitive passes and loud music
these things are um you know and they're
inconvenient um in some cases they've
done damage uh to boats and and docks
and things um you know I I think that uh
other comments and so I'll just be brief
uh you know other comments are accurate
that um uh you know this is a an
education issue uh not necessarily a
regulation issue uh imposing additional
uh limitations or uh restrictions um
don't necessarily prevent um any of
these things from happening and so I'm
excited to work with uh individuals that
want to point their time and energy and
resources to uh creating opportunities
to educate uh and influence behavior for
the voters and voter voting public um
you know to uh better utilize their
equipment more uh closely follow the
existing uh rules and uh regulations
that are out there and be good uh
stewards of the lake and good Sportsmen
um out there on the on the lake as well
thank you very
Dickerson David Dickerson I do not have
Dickerson or do I have a
David David it it could be on the phone
but I I don't know the name
mayot I got a Karen
man
Marie
May hi this is Karen um Marie is unable
to join okay can you hear me yes uh you
have do it do it under two minutes you
got the floor is yours you got it thank
you so much thank you so much for the
opportunity to speak my name is Karen
Maya and I'm a mother of three kids
under five and I'm a resident of Bedford
I've been boting my entire life on lakes
in our great state I oppose House Bill
229 to Define wake votes because I
honestly don't believe it'll solve any
of the issues brought forward by
proponents of the bill before us today I
believe this is the first step to
restricting the access to our
outstanding natural resources to only
certain activities while the problems
that proponents who have spoken ahead of
me brought forward will continue to
exist despite more laws in the books I
firmly believe Boer education is much
more critical than legislation when it
comes to safety and courteously
navigating our Waters my family
participates in multiple toad water
sports including water skiing wake
boarding wake surfing others as we teach
our kids to love the lake life our boat
would be defined as a wake boat with
this definition but by no means is it
only a wake boat we use our boat to take
folks in the disabled Community water
skiing in partnership with North East
passage out of Durham we like so many
others we know use our boat for cruising
floating date nights and so much more we
have three generations getting enjoyment
from our boat and especially this past
summer it was such a great outlet for
our mental health and to be together in
our Bay there are generally multiple
towboats out and we have had neighbors
purchase new towboats over the last
several years in our experience
educating our neighbors has been the
most effective way to ensure that all of
us have a great time safely and with
respect for our surrounding neighbors
Boer education is Paramount because we
already have laws on the books the 150
foot safe passage that ensures our
waters are safe and these laws apply to
all boats I ask this committee to not
focus on singling out a particular style
of boat that is not well understood or
quite frankly simple to at all but to
focus on educating voters and enforcing
the laws that we already have this is
where the real difference and
Improvement to our New Hampshire
waterways can be made thank you so much
for your time and I ask you to please
oppose House Bill
carry Jan
Gary are you there yep can you hear me
yeah all right thank you for the time my
name is Shane carry and I'm a resident
of Nottingham New Hampshire uh where I
live with my wife and two children um to
The Honorable members of the House of
resource and Recreation development
committee my name is Shane KY I live in
Nottingham on Paka lake with my family
who lived here in ninghan for 18 years
with our children and they go to Local
Schools I'm an avid water sports
Enthusiast and a towboat owner the
enjoys time on the water with his family
and friends I'm also a licensed New
Hampshire boat operator as well as a USA
water ski certified licensed driver my
family and I use our tobo with family
and friends to tube ski wakeboard and
just hang out and swim I have found that
it's the best way to spend quality time
with the kids their families their
friends um and I think that this is a
great diversion from the craziness of
today's world and keeps the screen time
down for the kids and gets them outside
engaging in outdoor activities with
friends and family my wife and I have
really enjoyed our time on the water
with the kids in their families and has
really helped develop great
relationships with their friends and get
to know more I've spent the last year as
a member of the House Bill 137
commission where we heard a lot of
testimony regarding wake boats it was
clear that the complaints we heard were
the result of negligent operators
usually going too close to shore when
participating in water sports after
almost a year of work we came to the
recommendation to support HB
115 which we spoke about earlier today
the bill about wake surf and safety we
did not come to a recommendation on
defining wake boat because the def to
Define wake boats is the wrong approach
I feel that the boats are not the
problem it is the education of the users
more emphas emphasis needs to be put on
education um rather than trying to
Define what a wake boat is uh real world
example we had a boater who lives on our
Lake that was upset in a few homeowners
because they were going too close to the
shore and going on the same path each
time I spoke with the boat owner owner
and made him aware of the people's
concern with this repeated boat path and
the requirement to be 150 ft or greater
from Shore or other boats the boat was
appreciative as he did not realize that
he was causing an issue I let him know
that he needed to be at least 150 F feet
from Shore and to change his boat path
each pass the boater has altered his way
and is now Towing um and stays 150 ft or
more from Shore as required does not
stay in the same boat path this was a
wiwin situation the homeowners are
happier the Boer is enjoying time with
lake I think your time has has expired
Witcher you got yeah Michael Witcher yep
can you hear
me uh yes I can hear you yeah I'll keep
it short um my name is Michael Witcher
uh I live in straford New Hampshire I
boat on B
Lake I'll speak for under a minute the
um I just want to say I am opposed to
this bill uh I am a toeo operator on B
Lake um I won't go on to say everything
everyone else has already said to save
your time and move on to the next person
but I
believe that this would lead its way to
regulate towboats and be a negative
thing in the future thank you thank you
very much finally our last speaker
McMahon so I I do not have a McMahon or
do I have B phone
number oh I'm sorry I missed I miss
excuse me
Tucker
yes
Tucker hi there can you hear me
yeah hi there I'll be I'll be real quick
because everybody has said everything
perfectly uh my name is hail col Tucker
I live in New London New Hampshire with
my wife Erica and three kids we boat on
Lake
uh been boting on Lake sopy for the past
five years um we're small business
owners in the State uh we operate
restaurants throughout the state and we
love New Hampshire and we love boating
in New Hampshire so we are here to
strongly oppose House Bill 229 uh which
looks to single out wake boats uh and I
think will undoubtedly pave the way for
further restrictions um I think we can
see where this is all headed um I I had
a long presentation and I'll and I'll um
submit that to the committee um
later but the key points are um please
do not let the actions of a few speak
for the many um I participate in uh
boating in Lake sopy with a large
community of like-minded people who
favor education um over restrictions and
just when the the Wake responsibility
campaign came out this year um I talked
to everybody that I could about the key
pillars of that campaign um and I think
those type of
educational um opportunities make a lot
of sense and I think that what you'll
find is the wake surf Community are
like-minded people they're people that
are just out trying to enjoy time with
their families and have a true Lust For
Life and they don't want to lose that
and so educational opportunities
everything that they can do to to
further the sport um they will do it um
and lastly I've had a unique opportunity
to see the wak surf Community um across
the country my son actually got
extremely passionate about it and uh
wakfs in competitions across the country
and I'll say the entire wak surf
Community across the country is like
that um we want to see the sport
continue to progress it's not going
anywhere um so let's make sure we do
everything we can to to promote
education um and that's that's all I
have thank you very much the uh that is
the last of those who wish to signed up
to speak so you have two people with
their hands up two people with
the
was someone named gen honorable price
but she already spoke and then you have
someone named Genesis who I don't know
Genesis if somebody who has not
spoken there staso also I don't know who
staso is staso yeah they just raised
okay St is up St good afternoon this is
Dennis
staco I would like to state that I
oppose House Bill
229 my family and I uh vat up on
Milton's three ponds in Milton New
Hampshire uh and I also agree with what
other folks have said about education I
believe education is the key to uh you
know uh safe boating conservative
boating I I believe that there are rules
and regulations already in place about
Shoreline
protection um I I don't think that wake
voting uh diminishes the the shoreline I
believe that it's unjust to classify one
single type of boat or one single type
of toe boo uh I agree with the majority
of the speakers that have already spoken
today and I appreciate you all listening
to us and uh hearing out our opposition
thank you thank you one more one more
more
Genesis
can okay I will be
very my name is
is that res
hello
still
Genesis
hello only once
hi can you hear me now I can can you
give your
fratkin did you spell
that f r a d k i n okay all right all
right just
just just literally to take a minute my
name is Dan fratkin I'm a resident of
molten Boro uh live on the shoreline so
very sensitive to wakes and Lake life
our whole family's been through Boer
education and our basic understanding is
is that you can have fun as long as your
fun doesn't disrupt other people and
that's how we've tried to
operate um so I wanted to really not
repeat everyone else's point but I think
the main thing is it's the boater not
the boat we've all seen people on jet
skis disrupting the fun of others we've
seen people on Big high-speed boats and
they can disturb others uh the the the
courtesy and the all of that is more
important than what is made on the boat
personally I would be I'm I'm all with
everyone else on the education and
enforcement and I think perhaps when you
register one of these boats you have to
say I agree to do these things if there
are repeated violations we need to deal
with those violators more than we need
to deal with a particular class of boats
so let me just wrap it up there and um
and just say that I I think everyone
needs to operate responsibly but taking
a class of boats that seems difficult to
Define and creating limitations for that
is not the right direction so I speak in
opposition to the
Bill thank you very much that's that's
the last
have 100 support the bill and
billly